okay
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is
[Music]
whether you
throw every time I hear that theme song
ring it makes me wanna sing
[Music]
[Music]
la la la
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
Alex Jones is now very very upset with
me
look that is a freaking Predator right
there he thinks he's smarter than you
and she better than you and he's gonna
beat you you Pac-Man never talked to the
new world war because Pac-Man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true I'm not a knight
at the round that that actually is
accurate that dude is gone crazy
[Music]
[Music]
who thinks he's smarter than you and
she's better than you and he's gonna
beat you
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed it is Trump
talking about massive dumps and by the
way extra points if you can sample Trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song please do it
big massive dumps
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what is going on here what is go what is
going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive ducks
cost of the election
what is gone here what is the what is
going on here
it's just beyond parody
of the election what
jumps
[Music]
[Music]
Pizza
[Music]
all right welcome everybody a very very
important Trump rally tonight in Arizona
now I know many of you I am sure are
likely assuming that complete lunatic
Cary Lake
she can't possibly have a real shot at
becoming the governor of Arizona and
then being in a position to try to steal
the electoral votes in Arizona in 2024
even if a Democratic candidate were to
win that couldn't possibly be the case
right well
read them and weep Arizona governor Lake
versus Hobbes in the Real Clear Politics
average
Kerry lake is ahead by one point
Kerry lake is ahead by one point in what
in a normal country
on a normal planet
in a sensible Galaxy
in a universe that made sense
this would be
a 60-point lead for Katie hops
extraordinarily disturbing and today's
rally is indeed in Arizona
at least in some theoretical context for
Donald Trump to support Kerry Lake
although of course the rallies are all
about himself
we're also monitoring other polling very
closely in a normal
country
Planet you know the whole thing
uh Herschel Walker would be losing by 50
points
and instead Rafael Warnock is leading by
not even four points now the only two
October polls were mostly done before
the Herschel Walker abortion Scandal and
even still you start to see this walker
decline so my hope is my hope is that by
Tuesday we have new polling done after
the abortion Scandal and it shows Walker
in the toilet
that would be the hope but we are going
to have to monitor that very closely
super chat's coming in David could you
email me your music video about mangoes
and loads and loads of money right yes
I'll just start emailing videos to
everybody good idea uh night docs no I'm
I'm kidding listen they're all online
but we I mean we don't have files we can
email but they're all available online
I'm not sure what you're looking to do
with it Javier but uh that's a question
for a different day uh night ducks have
you seen Johnny Harris's New York Times
video on Election rigging I have not
allow me to view it first before uh
before commenting so very very important
stuff why did I not stream last night
well last night uh so on Friday late
Friday I got the omnicron vaccine
and yesterday even today still a little
under the weather but yesterday was a
very powerful flu-like day and I was in
no condition to do a stream by the way
Trump didn't even start speaking till
like after 10 p.m or was it even 11 P 10
30 something like that it was not for me
it was not for me yesterday but glad to
be back today
glad to be back today I do want to say
thank you to some incredible people
William raybrock Jason sickmeyer between
the two of them gifting three
subscriptions and really kicking us off
today and over on Twitch a big thank you
to floor mat chunky strudel Miss scorp
uh all signing up via twitch Prime
putting us at six we are hoping to get
to 100 today
and I believe that you were all going to
help us make it happen oh also thanks to
Jason sickmeyer and Kevin gouldi for
gifting two more subscriptions putting
us at eight
which I very much love so take a look at
this venue at which this rally is taking
place it's a pathetic and humiliating
venue there's video here and it's
basically dirt and they've put folding
chairs
on the dirt and it's like quite frankly
the middle of the desert and it just
looks absolutely horrible horrible
horrible horrible and you know some of
you find folks have asked me uh like why
don't I go to some of these rallies and
there's a lot of reasons why but one of
the the reasons is I've said before you
think I want to be fighting with people
for sanican Access and just in these
fetid horrible venues now in this one
it's just the chairs are on top of each
other it's just dirt it's horrible and
by the way I'm not an anti-arizona guy I
love Arizona uh I have friends in
Arizona I've spent extended periods of
time in Arizona just hanging out
uh and it's great it's great not even
shade guys I mean it's like I hope
everybody's wearing their sunscreen by
the way I alluded to this the other day
and there were people very curious about
it I'm not going to be endorsing any
particular products but I am fully on uh
South Korean sunscreen now
I know a lot of people saying sir crying
why why did you abandon American
sunscreen just look into
South Korean sunscreen this is actually
a serious thing in in many other
countries including in Europe they've
already approved other elements for
sunscreen whereas in the U.S we're
basically stuck with the same few for a
very long time thanks to the FDA there
are extraordinary light
not you know with the whole the cake uh
sunscreens but not the bad ingredients
the Ben zones and all of that stuff
um I'm fully I'm fully on now I'm not
endorsing any brand this isn't a sponsor
or anything like that talk to your
dermatologist get screenings for skin
cancer every year you know do all the
things
but um
just look into it okay South Korean
sunscreen very very important stuff okay
other super chats coming in Bronx the
thing that scares me about Carrie is how
relatable she is to conservatives who
voted for Obama in 2008 the grift's a
gift but it's relatable which does not
bode well for the Challenger agree a
hundred percent
a hundred percent thank you to S Prez
for gifting 20 subscriptions on Twitch
and thanks to Tina tiru for the twitch
subscription as well number 29 very very
much appreciate that we have a coupon
code today the code is indict to save
massively
joinpakman.com
okay coupon code
in day
powerful stuff
Christopher Martin Digger up Ivanka
holds Secrets I think you mean Ivana
but I'm not even getting involved in
that whole thing
uh
Cody Culp says the ignorance of one
voter in a democracy impairs the
security of all JFK what can be done
about the sheer ignorance of the
American voter it seems like democracy
can be hijacked by the ignorant any
solutions it honestly it go it's such a
systemic issue it goes back to
edumacation to a great degree and it's a
multi-generational problem which doesn't
get fixed with like memes you know
I wish it did
I wish it did but it doesn't
s press ain't here for second place
that's exactly right uh s Prez is the
top gifter
of all time on the twitch Channel which
is an incredible thing
truly an incredible thing all right
let's look at a couple other uh videos
actually Let me refresh here to make
sure we've got all of the newest content
for us
um oh here's Pillow by the way you know
I didn't announce this but Mike pillow
is going to be back on the program after
trolling my uh Facebook page he is going
to be on on Tuesday I don't think I
announced it but people started emailing
me about pillow gonna be back on the
show did he announce it I don't I don't
think it was me
does anybody know how people how did has
he been saying something about it
I don't even know let's listen to what
he had to say the scary thing about what
happened was it was the middle of the
day none of them looked like that yeah
they didn't show badges right away it
could have been a night I've been around
the block I would have bashed through
them and I would have been a high-speed
chase to find along towards right that's
the scary part you know they didn't they
didn't uh it wasn't like you pull up
with sunglasses and FBI right
so pillow almost uh ran from police
that's super interesting kind of
surprising I have to tell you
uh Carey Lake made a transphobic speech
that's not a surprise let me see what
else we have from the rally oh by the
way I told you guys about this the fetid
Sani cans look at this Carrie Lake got
off stage it's 87 degrees but there's no
cloud coverage so people are getting
into the shade created by the fetid
porta potties to get relief what a
horrible situation this is why I don't
go to these things
look at this
oh my God it is horrifying
[Music]
[Applause]
who on Earth would go to this stuff it's
horrible here's
um Marjorie Trader green I guess at the
same rally Mary Garland
[Music]
Hillary Clinton declared us all
deplorable and ever since that day the
media and the Democrats and those in
charge have treated all of us
that not only means
positive opinions in our speech it also
means our lives Democrats cheers finally
made it in says Arizona right wing watch
a couple more medical emergencies while
I waited in line including a woman
nursing a newborn oh my God what are
these people doing also spotted the
Mormon cosplay and Gladiator in line
again he wouldn't confirm it was Nathan
enterkin nervous well Dear God
Criminal
should be completely Criminal
uh let's listen to a little bit of the
Carrie Lake speech Let's Run reminisce
now let's go back to the good old days
just a few years ago when President
Trump was in charge
remember this we had a record-breaking
economy we had Law and Order Safe
Streets we had a secure border man I'd
never seen anything like that it was
tight
we were optimistic everything was going
well
and now 19 months later it feels like
we're living in a third world country
yeah I think I feel the same way right I
mean it's so it's incredible how much
things have changed so quickly oh wait
no they really haven't actually
thanks to hegelic as well as raided Roy
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at 31. continuing just uh you
know Trump's speaking in a little bit
Newsmax will eventually carry it and so
will right side broadcasting we're
standing by for Trump but in the
meantime we're checking out some some
videos here are oh no that's not new I
want to do I want to do new stuff
um
some of these are just so horrible
though
as usual with an Arizona mega rally
there have been multiple medical
emergencies I've seen stretchers come
and go three times and some people in
the VIP just called for medical
attention again food trucks running out
of drinks no water allowed inside it's
outdoors
oh my God
it's just unbelievable
David sir how about Trump mispronouncing
names and places I think I have some of
those things here
let's see what do I have
to leave
we've endorsed JP right JD Mandel by the
way tomorrow night is the JD Vance
versus Tim Ryan debate I will be live
with it on YouTube twitch and Facebook
that's okay we've endorsed JP right JD
Mandel yep other mispronunciations oh
oh remember when Trump mispronounced his
own name then he went Donald Trump yeah
Donald Trump yeah a rhino name grimney
right
s and Jesse James Billy the cut I'm
really good man I love that one all
right super chat's coming in
David did you see Marjorie Trader
Green's husband powerfully filed for
divorce I did see that I did
Carrie Lake had an interview on 60
Minutes Australia she was the laughing
stock of our entire country I did see
that interview it was it was bonkers
what the hell happened with Kanye going
wild again I know it's what a shock
Kanye's anti-semitic who could who could
have guessed it living in Arizona it's
typical to be outdoors in this seat for
example maybe the state fair but an
election speech when you're stuck in
place for hours not so much well said
uh David love the show keep it up
if it's TMI I totally understand but
I've been wondering what's your
daughter's name congrats on the new baby
oh it's shashana Rifka
a nice uh nice Jewish name shashana
Rifka
uh Blake Daniel with the gifted
subscription and is number 32 today very
much appreciate that also thanks to dexy
for the twitch Prime subscription an
important thing let's listen just a
little to see what they're talking about
their local you know
you know parties
get all these people Americans are
waking up they're they're awake they get
it let me ask you a question do you
think there's news producers right now
at uh you CNN and a lot of other uh you
know Legacy Media that are looking at
this and going what in the world is
going on this guy's out of office two
years the population still swell are
they scared of the midterms they are
when they see Trump speaking to a couple
thousand people sitting on dirt they
really go whoa
this guy May really have the staying
power
that really this we've got to really pay
attention to this
uh man
it's it's wild out there
here's a guy with like a trump balloon
sort of thing
um
[Laughter]
one of my favorite Clips we covered this
this was Trump in front of a Hispanic
crowd with a double glitch double glitch
but no teacher should ever be allowed to
teach transgender to our children well
parent don't think so so you can't teach
transgender without parental consult and
then he went right into a second glitch
no nobody has to have parental consent
and we will totally oppose the Biden
Administration they're against the Biden
administrating that's that's one of my
favorites of 2022.
um let's see what else we have
here's Marjorie at the rally Joe Biden's
five million illegal aliens are on the
verge of replacing you replacing your
jobs and that's called the Great
replacement Theory they're not even
hiding it anymore placing your kids in
school and coming from all over the
world they're also replacing your
culture right and that's not great for
America right
right
very very dangerous declaration
uh let's see what we have here's pillow
being interviewed
Steve I would walk down the street you
know me Brian they all come out to me
wanting pictures but they wanted to know
they wanted pictures pictures of what
water I guess because it's so hot you
know it's your stuff is this stuff real
when the voting machines and stuff and
they see the problems with the gas and
everything so they're coming they're
going to vote or not vote you understand
yeah I don't think they're gonna either
vote for for the um that's true I mean
they're either going to vote or they're
not going to vote I agree with that
those are definitely the two options 100
of the people are gonna fall into those
one of those two categories I no no
disagreement at all with pillow
Republican right they're not going to
vote at all I believe you're going to
have a lot of non-voters here you're
going to have the biggest turnout of
Republicans in a midterm in the history
of our world yeah our world wow we have
a world
uh yeah so pillow will be joining me on
Tuesday that should be that should be
pretty pretty interesting
um
let's see what else we got yeah Michael
J fox really that's sad what's going on
um
what else did we have from the rally
yeah they're selling grift gear
Dr Oz having an issue with his hair okay
not not gonna follow that right now
um man maybe that is it from the rally
now just some kind of random pictures
horrible traffic
open field tackle on a person rating
uh they're having an issue with the
metal detectors let's see and of course
uh we were planning on being inside
right now but they've got a little bit
of problems a technical I guess the
magmatometers magma tominers oh they're
measuring they're I guess there's
volcanic activity they're worried about
I thought the issue was with the
magnetometers which you and I might know
as a metal detector
the magmatometers there could be there
could be a volcano ready to explode
and so they've it's been there's been a
delay being reset so we want to make
sure that the metal detectors work right
gotta make sure the metal detectors work
looking over the line I don't see it I
don't know if it's moving but I think
this is the meta detector I mean this
this guy for someone who's done doing
broadcast
some of the worst diction truly truly
we've said this before I want to know
where the left is gathering on a Sunday
afternoon right and having this many
people show up they're not I mean
they're not and they're happy right now
because it's not a cult
it's not a cult
a woman who is a speed Faith artist
shows off the painting of trump she did
watch as a prince
and I really saw the country going in a
bad Direction
um so I started praying for you know for
answers and just seeking God and I
started just feeling like it was on my
heart to pray that he would run for
office so when he was totally normal
totally normal
I was all about it and
are behind him from day one so
one so this is a dream
if some people want to you know go on a
safari some people want to uh
you know save as many lives as possible
by going into medicine some people's
dream is to be able to paint at a trump
rally in the desert
yeah I mean good great
uh let's see what else we have
oh this is interesting
and what brought you
brought you what
went forward to see from you today oh my
gosh the unity and the healing and just
move on and we just have to heal as a
nation and come together again yep and
everybody knows that at a trump rally
he really brings everybody together Left
Right communist Marxist capitalists yeah
the whole uh the whole thing man
um geez
thanks to Boba fetra and dexy for the
twitch Prime subscriptions numbers 34
and 35. I very very very much appreciate
that how is the finance Channel doing
well
this is super exciting
Pacman Finance has now breached the 10
000 subscriber mark this is a
non-political channel
um hold on a second we we just we're I
think today is like a record for how
many people were Banning per minute it's
crazy uh the Pacman Finance channel is
now Beyond 10 000 subscribers I
encourage you to check out the channel
it's just Financial stuff learn about
credit score bear Market IRAs
uh asset allocation inflation all these
different things okay you missed your
chance to be one of the first thousand
you missed your chance to be one of the
first five thousand you've missed your
chance to be one of the first ten
thousand but believe you me
when this thing goes nuclear you will
wish that you were in
in the first 25
000. so this is a great great time
to uh to join up I encourage you to do
it as we are standing by here for Donald
Trump do any minute any minute
uh super chats no all right let's
continue with some of our the flavor and
the color of the Trump rally here's more
interviews except they're on the other
side and they have bad intentions for
this country so just go out and be
honest speak the truth speak from the
heart be who you are and people will
respect that totally reasonable outfit
uh in the desert yeah Amen to that let's
see if we can back off just a little bit
give us some rooms there you go thank
you all right so and I love your shirt
by the way but we can't really show that
on TV oh wait what was going on hold on
be who you are and people will respect
that yeah Amen to that let's see if we
can back off just a little bit give us
some rooms here you go thank you could
anybody see what the guy's shirt was
there
all right so and I love your shirt by
the way but we can't really show that on
TV there you go all right thank you very
much no no it's all good there you go he
knew what he was doing all right so
we're glad you're out here you can't get
past me man yeah
weird
cheers
uh
oh here's the worship speed artist
performing huh yeah so is she she's just
living her element she's a beautiful
woman painting for a large crowd of
American Patriots and obviously really
fun to watch Christina it's a spiritual
moment for her as well on this on this
Sunday she's having quite literally a
come to Jesus moment on this Sunday uh
it's this very spiritual moment uh that
she's having with us right now and it's
just beautiful
uh-huh wow
that's that's a lot A lot's happening
there
uh all right is that it no here's more
also lost a lot of friends because I'm a
trump fan I don't understand it but you
know what we're all for we're all
global-ish all in for him yeah yeah you
know what we're going to pray for those
people who cannot open their eyes and
find out how great Trump is for this
country and Kerry Lake and of course you
got the whole roster of some great
conservative Republicans represent the
state yes sir and remember none of these
people are conservative they're just
reactionary extremists there's nothing
conservative about them okay you got
your second amendment as well I love
that God's gone guts Second Amendment
what what is wrong with these people
everything yeah look at you and you know
what you got a cool haircut I'm hoping
all right so everything going very very
well uh what's happening here that's
okay
[Laughter]
and that's actually a fair point there's
more media here than at most of the
rallies like a lot more media well you
know there's you know like they said hey
you guys know why right
it's because local media is covering
Kerry Lake I mean that that's why it's
like as far as the people the the people
covering the Trump rally it's right side
broadcasting and it's Newsmax
um all right so we're expecting Donald
Trump any moment I'm I'm very glad to
have you all here even if it is for such
an absurd event that makes no sense that
it's even happening
um but I'm still glad to have you all
here let's see if we can do a voicemail
uh
uh let's see
David I have a question for you if
modern conservatism
was a sandwich
what sandwich what kind of famous
sandwich would it be it would be a pizza
in the sense that there there's modern
conservatism doesn't really exist it's
just reactionary nuttery it's just
something different it's not a sandwich
anymore it's a different type of food
that's the crazy thing
[Music]
I called the other night about your
wearing your badge of soy boy
and I mentioned shoshana Juliet I was
often name
and I said well I have that in my
imagination her name is shoshana and I
like that name it's not a regular name
and I might you just announced it here
while we're waiting for
um djg and I'm like I was so excited I
had to call
and um
confusing are you psychic
no not really
all right very very important
declarations hey David
this has been in California
I think you're vastly underrating
under rating Donald Trump
the only way he won't run for office
or you won't get into office if he's
convicted of a crime
that prevents him from running for
office
or if he passes away okay
but let's say he doesn't even run for
any office right remember
if the Republicans taking the house over
that means they can put any speaker vows
in there it doesn't have to be somebody
from the House of Representatives
and they're thinking about putting
Donald J Trump as Speaker of the House
right as crazy as that may sound
so Donald Trump
must be considered until he is no longer
valid to run or hold any office again
wow
impressive stuff
impressive stuff
uh let's see what else we got here
David sir just want to say a big fan of
the show just
just found uh I know this is for stuff
to get played on there this isn't it
played on the air but on the top right
then I'll turn it off uh it's only for
stuff to get played on air I I the idea
that I'm going to have time to listen to
voicemails not to be played on air if
it's not for air then you know you gotta
email in if it's anything else
um okay
other things going on
uh oh uh people are saying there's
something not nutty going on let's see
wrong with him he loves this nation
greatness and make it greater than it's
ever been and that's what they're afraid
of yeah that's what they're afraid of
okay so we got Georgia Pennsylvania
Wisconsin Michigan we're gonna be there
for election night and we've talked
about this before I'm not quite sure
where you're gonna go but hey
Pennsylvania we're gonna I hope yep and
we're gonna be uh all over the country
covering this of course we'll be live
from our right side Studios there in
Alabama going live there I'll be there
with Vanessa Broussard in studio we'll
have Liz Willis in the Herschel Walker
Camp I'll have someone here in Arizona I
would love to go to Arizona of course I
think but I got it we're gonna I've got
to hold it down the fort there uh but
we're gonna be all over the place so
make sure that you really set your
reminders on your phone to tune in to us
because a lot of people haven't
traditionally yeah you wouldn't you
wouldn't want to miss that Newsmax
running a Mike Huckabee commercial
that's interesting sleep Mike had real
difficulty getting to sleep and staying
asleep until you started taking relaxing
sleep for years now we both fall asleep
faster stay asleep longer and wake up
refreshed every morning it's made life a
whole lot better and since relaxing
sleeps formula is so safe and effective
yeah let's see what's in it I'm sort of
like Curious let's see relaxium
um
you get free bottles here's actors
promoting it
um
it's vegan and gluten free okay but like
what are the ingredients let's see
do they make it deliberately difficult
to figure out like what's in it
okay
key ingredients include melatonin from
what I've read not particularly good to
take long term L-tryptophan
that's the thing in turkey that
everybody says oh it makes you sleepy
the amount you have to have is like
crazy
Gaba
so yeah the thing about Gaba is Gaba is
if I if I know the terminology correctly
sort of like
released or generated by the brain as
you get close to sleeping but it's I
don't believe it's proven that taking
Gaba
does what
they think it does
and then herbs oh ashwagandha valerest
hops Valerian I'm pretty sure Valerian
it's not good to take long term there's
some kind of health issue with that and
then chamomile I don't think there's
anything yeah so this is this is this is
nothing it's melatonin with additives
and you probably shouldn't be taking
melatonin long term so I would not get
that not a medical opinion but I I would
not
I would not get that that's what
Huckabee is promoting all right
um
oh people want one more voicemail oh
thanks to chobo styles for the twitch
Prime subscription number 36. oh let me
just do this I'm gonna do this once and
then we will we will get Beyond it okay
I have oh actually let's listen to
pillow
you know what's interesting I was in a
hotel this morning and someone was
getting ready and I heard the
conversation about going to see
President Trump and this one lady
hesitated I think she made it like a
reaction the guy goes what you want
communism in this country is that what
you're voting for she goes well what is
the definition of communism he said put
a democrat in office and you'll find
exactly what combination looks like
because they have no idea what it is uh
Mike pillow will be joining me on the
show Tuesday Mike pillow will be joining
me on the show Tuesday and uh maybe we
can we can talk to him about this listen
real quick okay
um our program is mostly funded by our
viewers I would love for you to grab a
membership today quite quite simply and
quite frankly we have a dozen different
debates that I'm going to be be covering
between now and election day it's all
funded by memberships tomorrow night is
JD Vance versus Tim Ryan Wednesday is
Ron death santis versus Charlie Crist
Thursday we have two debates Mandela
Barnes versus Ron Johnson and Gretchen
Whitmer versus Tudor Dixon
Friday we have Rafael Warnock versus
Herschel Walker if it happens so there's
a debate almost every single night next
week there's another Vance versus Ryan
debate Marco Rubio and Val demings the
Minnesota gubernatorial debate the week
after that we've got Oz versus fetterman
which should be interesting all of these
things okay funded by the membership
program the ask is really simple okay
you go to joinpakman.com you can do
yearly you can do monthly okay either
way it's your choice
the coupon code it's above my head it's
indict you type the coupon code in
unbelievable and beautiful things happen
okay if you want an even even bigger
discount you type in Obama Obama
I won't even say the percentage discount
because it's crazy okay
as a member you get an extra show every
single day
you get the Regular Show six hours
before everybody else and it really is
our primary source of funding so I would
love it if folks grab memberships today
I will thank every single one of you and
we will continue to pray
we will continue to pray
for the indictment
of Donald Trump if it's appropriate
legally see how that's Law and Order I
don't go throw people in jail I go
if the evidence points to it
we hope for the indictment
see how that is that's Law and Order
it's not me saying indict this jail that
all the different stuff okay
um
where were we we were in the middle of
so many different things quite frankly
uh let's Okay people want to hear a
pillow and they said well why would they
like to release the 2020 election
finally I said they went last Montgomery
to it I go well now they know I own it
so maybe they're going that's my
evidence Brian you think I can't for six
billion dollars worth of lawsuits you'd
think I'm not going to bring that out
well let's talk about the money you've
spent Mike and we've talked about you
here on this network all throughout the
day
you've invested a lot of your own money
my interview with pillow on Tuesday is
going to be different than this just so
you all know
just so everybody knows
that said to me Mike what are you gonna
quit I'm never gonna quit till these
machines are gone Brian I don't care if
I have to sell everything we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines half a year ago but now
everybody stepped it up the whole
country so as far as I am doing their
own investigation getting task vote
records and getting all these things but
one of the things
um that's been great is that throughout
that I didn't have to worry as much
about my employees because the way your
audience responded everybody and bought
my pillow products to help our employees
code RSB and everybody
rsvn promo code you got to do it a
matter of fact before Trump comes out
here you got to fill you got a couple
minutes just go to the website guys your
choices are MyPillow coupon code rsbn
or join Pacman coupon code Obama
quite a choice quite a contrast
that's what you do so we now have a we
have an Overstock sale too you can save
some of the products
I mean I don't know people realize we
have my pillow sleepwear we have
bathrobes we have all this stuff that's
on sale when people come up to your mic
I have all your products and they'll
name the slippers the sheets the towels
and the pillow and maybe the bed topper
but then wait a minute we have over 500
products yeah and then also everybody a
big announcement and
mystore.com this is my platform for
entrepreneur is this the one that was
attacked after the FBI rape those guys
were pulling up on Michael's got FBI's
after him which which is a joke but in
mystore.com we launched yesterday we're
announcing it here the my store shopping
channel which you can also I made sure
you could use the promo code RSB in
there over there's thousands of products
buying all made in the USA by
entrepreneurs you can watch see their
store Aries it's amazing it was amazing
and you engage in and the shopping
Channel's got the video of you I mean
you're talking about products they're
talking about what you like about it
yeah I said that hey I wish I had my
coffee up here matter of fact I think
I'm gonna help Brian come on to do the
coffee I would sign me up really
impressive stuff going on there in the
meantime back in the world that sane I
actually want to say thanks to Avery
mazarik massarick for signing up at
joinpakman.com and then also Juan and
Jason as well as Jason and Jason Jason
gifting three membership appreciate four
people gifting memberships I I genuinely
appreciate you folks when you have a
choice in coupon codes where you could
go to my pillow or you go to my website
I genuinely appreciate that I know you
have choices when it comes to coupon
codes
and uh I I appreciate you using my dear
God what what a mess what a mess at this
rally Trump expected 20 minutes ago and
he should be out anytime thanks to David
J blueberry babe and Melody for the
twitch Prime subscriptions putting us at
44. the goal is 100. voicemails yeah
I've got a couple other voicemails for
you
hello David it's Jason Colfax from
Colorado I wish I was down there in
Arizona
so I could sell these fools a hundred
dollar bottles of water and probably
some kind of lie about how it heals you
yeah uh that's what I've learned well
you weren't allowed to bring in bottled
water apparently it's completely nuts
um Sarah says ilhan will win in
Minneapolis but it will be closer than
the last election her primary was very
close I think it's her defund the police
rhetoric that set her back what are your
thoughts I genuinely don't know because
I don't know the Dynamics of that
District but yeah I think like uh I
think ilhan Omar won like I'm making
these numbers up but it was like her
first primary she won super easily her
second one she won easily but the last
one she only won by like two or
something like that so her margin has
been shrinking but I have no idea why no
idea why thanks to Brent Penton and Sean
labreck for signing up at joinpakman.com
new members 45 and 46 very very much
appreciate that
um Trump do any minute yep any minute
couple other voicemails hey David I'm
stoked to hear your interview with
pillow on Tuesday yeah after watching
his recent uh interview at the rally ask
him how much sleep he gets because I
guarantee you it's like less than an
hour a night thanks oh that's not bad
yeah let me ask him that I'm going to
put that on the list here hold on pillow
we've got a pillow file
um
new questions
do not delete for October 11 interview
how much sleep do you get that's a good
question I am curious about that
uh
put that in the pillow file
we have a file
uh okay
so a viewer just emailed me the relaxion
pills their mom bought them
uh
I love that drug free you're basically
conceding
it's nothing like it's that's a it's
fascinating
contains no GMO gluten nuts yeast sugar
dairy eggs tree nuts fish shellfish soy
corn wheat barley or artificial
ingredients
yeah magni oh this one has magnesium
yeah magnesium for sleep is a that's
been floating around for a while I'm not
familiar off hand oh it also has like no
melatonin that's interesting where it it
act they're acting like melatonin's the
main thing there's almost no melatonin
in it anyway buy the pills if you want I
mean I'm just you know
it's a field I'm a little bit familiar
with and I don't know
that I would uh necessarily go in that
direction it's up to you though always
up to you
uh all right the pronunciation thing is
an epidemic guy on YouTube calls world
number one tennis
alcares every time alternating every
other time drives me crazy yeah
Ulysses S Grant remember that one for
the pillow file consideration why does a
pillow man sell coffee isn't it a
contradiction how can I fall asleep if
I'm all wired oh that's a good question
too let me put that in my pillow file
I need you all producing some of these
interviews
is there a contradiction between selling
coffee and selling pillows well it's
sort of like getting people sick and
then selling them the Cure you know I
mean it's it's quite profitable I bet
thanks to Nicholas Aaron for signing up
at joinpakman.com you're a new member
number 47 folks let's do something crazy
new member number 50 on my website you
get a free item from my online store
whether you want a coffee mug or
whatever anywhere in the world I will
send it to you whoever is number 50
today so number 50.
such a strange location for a rally it's
barely even in Mesa yeah I mean it looks
like it's in the middle of nowhere I
know they claim it's in Mesa Arizona but
uh
it seems to be basically in the middle
of nowhere
it's all very odd here's another
voicemail
hi David uh my name is Ryan I'm from
Ottawa Canada and I'm just calling you
um because so in the next couple years
we're gonna have the potential to have
uh three conservative
um
anglosphere
all political leaders so there's the
potential to have whether it be a trump
or a Ron DeSantis
uh
presidency or uh in Canada have
pierre-paulia get elected
um and in in the UK
um potentially Liz truss
or if she gets like ousted
um okay it it's going on a little bit I
would say call in call in and we'll get
uh
will get right down to business on that
one
[Music]
all right we'll listen to a little more
we get a little
sister on the tip jar here right side
which is nice supporting the best news
Outlet ever rsbn they've been they've
had their presidents back they've had my
back Chris for I don't know almost a
decade no at least six years yeah and uh
use promo code rspn you guys you support
my employees so I can go out and do the
things that I have to get done get rid
of these machines yeah support rsbn they
there's other outlets getting the word
out but you guys have been there yeah
from the beginning and you were the only
ones at certain times Mike we love you
we really appreciate it God bless you
we'll see you all right I'll go get the
the machine there she comes the greatest
broadcaster here in Arizona Christina
Bob said I can never get injured how can
you follow Mike Lindell now hi can you
follow Mike Lindell it's hard to follow
him oh I know Michael that was the
greatest yeah I do think the president's
coming out soon though you do because
they were supposed to be some candidates
I was I was listening to the calms
people talking they were supposed to
come back to do more media okay and they
okay so a lot clearly happening there
and very very important stuff I want to
say thanks to Stephanie epright William
Jameson and Travis Stewart for signing
up on my website thank you thank you
thank you putting us at 50 and of course
number 50 is the last one I mentioned
Travis Stewart Travis you get a free
item from the online store email info
davidpackman.com to claim it also thanks
to Jason sickmeyer for gifting a
subscription on my website David sir ask
pillow if he owns right side
broadcasting it seems their entire
purpose is advertising his business he
doesn't own it as far as as far as I'm
aware
David if Trump told them the romulans
Klingons Khan and the green Sheik helped
steal the election they'd believe him
yeah they believe everything look at
these people sitting in direct sun for
hours on dirt with feted Sani cans
it's horrible
horrible they're going to be totally
burned out by the time the thing even
starts the way this is going
super chats continue dumping in
hey David I'm sorry voicemails I mean I
know you were talking a lot about
Herschel Walker in the recent Scandal
and Republicans
um I haven't heard anyone talking about
this but
social Walker fits the exact stereotype
that every racist has about black people
he's violent with the domestic abuse
that his son has accused him of and his
wife uh he's a brute he's a football you
know I know the point that this person
is getting to I'm going to get away from
this just because I'm I'm reading ahead
the transcript and it gets a little bit
dicey so I'm going to get away from that
I'm gonna get away from that
um here is Juan with a question about I
guess the sleep medication we were
looking at there which by the way has no
medication in it hey David uh
not all non-drugs
don't have drug-like effects
not all
non-drugs
don't have
don't have drug-like effects
uh hold on let me see if I can figure
this out okay
so you've got drug-like effects
don't have drug-like effects
don't have drugs
non-drugs
non-drugs don't have drug-like effects
not all
non-drugs
don't have drug-like effects
I can't figure I for the life of me I
can't figure it out
I can't figure I literally cannot figure
that out not all non-drugs
don't have damn I that is really
complicated
so what so like a non-drug like a banana
not all bananas
don't have drug-like effects which means
some bananas
have drug-like effects right
some bananas have drug-like effects yeah
okay so
that's interesting
that's interesting man Juan you're
really keeping me on my toes today my
friend that is that is serious stuff
uh wow wow
thanks to Watermelon Man for the twitch
Prime subscription your new member
number 52 today I also want to say
thanks to Nick jowet Adam Taylor Heather
lemmer and Michelle Scott thank you for
signing up on my website you are putting
us at 56 folks we have a coupon code the
code is Obama you type it in at
joinpakman.com you get the bonus show
you get the commercial free audio and
video feeds of the show and maybe most
importantly I say your name I say your
name on this live stream which is maybe
the best thing going
maybe maybe the best thing going
there are non-drug substances that have
drug-like effects yes like said like
that it makes sense now that I got hey
David a quick question so
um obviously unfortunately it looks like
the Republicans are gonna are gonna take
control of the house uh what do you
think is gonna happen in regards to the
debt ceiling if you know Republicans
take control uh what I mean by this is
you know I feel like they're just going
to vote against
um uh approving the death steering uh
they did this like last year and
um I heard that bad things could happen
so I was wondering like what would
happen if you know they reject like the
deaf ceiling though uh what would happen
to our economy
yeah it listen this question comes up so
often I don't have anything new to add
let's it's it's so speculative let's
just wait and see let's just wait and
see
um
yeah
shout out to Deb B says Seven Dust thank
you it's hard loving my trump loving
parent says Joe it's sad I don't have
Cher their value system indeed
that does sound tough
thanks to Savvy lemons and burger B for
the twitch Prime subscriptions let's
listen to what's going on see if we can
get an update about Trump's ETA leaders
respected America and they respected
president Trump nobody respects Joe
Biden I mean he's rumored to have pooped
his pants with the Pope it doesn't get
any more embarrassing there you go take
them seriously nobody takes America
seriously we're a laughing stock right
now and that's because of Joe Biden and
Democrats stupid policies that nobody
respects us yeah that's it and a period
and of course you know president Trump
in office he told the Taliban all the
the Isis leaders that if you kill an
American that that will be the last
thing that you do and so he really put
fear in our enemies and that's why under
the Trump Administration we had zero
for the last few years for the last few
years yeah I think with the last 18
months or 24 months yeah
um no but I I mean we try to pretend
that we take the moral high road yeah
Hey listen I want to get um everybody's
advice on something
there's the moderators just brought to
my attention that there is someone in
twitch chat
just typing over and over
covet vaccine increases Cardiac Arrest
by 84 percent that coveted vaccine
increases increases Cardiac Arrest rate
84 now this has already been totally
debunked okay this was a study quote
study a self-study apparently done by
the
um very very weaponized
medical guy from Florida I forget the
guy's name
and um it's like specifically the group
18 to 39 and I think maybe only males
it's a group that has like almost no
cardiac arrest and so it's one of these
small numbers things where like even
even if true that it's 84 higher like
even if it was perfectly done 84 it's
still almost no cardiac arrest
um it's not it's not actual science
should we ban that person or like I've
addressed it now maybe if they say it
again
then we ban them because they're just
they're just like Mass posting about
that over and over and over again
maybe we banned them I don't know
just ban them
yeah listen like we don't have to go
back up and find it but if we see it
again just ban them it's just it's so
stupid it's very very stupid
um I mean like think think about how
insane that would be think think about
that
the entire vaccinated population of the
world which at this point is it like is
it bill is it in the billions have over
a billion people gotten the vaccine
84 increase in heart attacks in the 30
days that follow like come on guys like
you use your head at some point you got
to apply the sniff test you know
um
okay DB Rising Arizona Republican leader
and orange Mafia darling Kelly Ward just
pleaded the fifth to the select
committee we will look at that we will
look at that very strongly thanks to
Brian Cherry for signing up at
joinpakman.com new member number
59 59 very much appreciate that yes
people asking I did indeed get the
omnicron booster on Friday
terrible arm pain even still
uh very flu-like yesterday terrible
headache and just a whole bunch of uh
you know aches
hot no fever but felt very hot
and I'm doing uh doing much better today
doing much better today
voicemails are continuing to just pour
in
hi David it's Frank from Florida
can't wait to watch Tuesday night
there's some chatter on the internet
about Trump asking pillow to run for VP
that's going to be their ticket imagine
that uh and you can ask them if there's
any truth to that
thanks
uh that's not a bad question I mean I
don't think he would tell me
but I I think it might be interesting
just to get his reaction has Trump
spoken to you about being his VP has
Trump spoken to you and I'll butter him
up like because you're so beloved
because you're so beloved
within the Maga movement
some have speculated that you could be
Trump's 2024 VP
has Trump spoken to you about that I'm
putting this in my pillow file
uh that'll that could be interesting
could be interesting David want to say
thank you for the finance Channel my
family or Big Dave Ramsey fans your
channel has helped me a lot well my
pleasure Mason yeah we've got a new
channel it is the Pacman Finance Channel
you can find it at youtube.com
pacmanfinance oh hold on we can't even
see
let's see here there we go
uh it's a great Channel it really is and
we've gotten our first first 10 000
subscribers and it is a beautiful
beautiful thing uh Trump's about 40
minutes late
expected any moment expected quite quite
literally any moment here
um oh other voicemails yeah they're
they're pouring in here
hey David
I usually go by the handle micro Cami on
Twitch but uh my name is Kimmy I'm from
Schertz Texas
and I just wanted to bring to your
attention please
a
amusement park or
I don't even know what to call it but it
was a place I went to on field trips as
a child in Edmond Oklahoma it was called
Enterprise Square and websites
still exist
hello
what the hell
please don't play this
okay well
too late for that Kimmy I'm sorry but a
very sounds very interesting
sounds very interesting Michael says uh
anybody spreading covid disinfo this
late in the game is acting in bar faith
I guess bad faith it should be Auto band
no question about it Zero Tolerance yeah
I tend to kind of go in that direction
at this point
that does that does make a lot of sense
to me
um let's see what else we have here
David I almost choked on the supplement
after you played my voicemail
um I would have neither real drugs if I
really choked on it
that was hilarious man all right but you
should listen to the voicemail
that I left about uh
the military well we've already played
two of your voicemails why I don't know
that we're going to be able to do that
let's see David quick question and this
is not political would you invite the
world's best player Lionel Messi to the
David Pacman show of course thanks man
of course in fact I already
um
I already ordered a uh an Argentina
soccer onesie
for my daughter what would the World Cup
coming up I think it's going to be it's
going to be very very interesting gonna
be very very interesting World Cup
looking forward to it very very strongly
I want to say thank you to Frank Jones
Carrie Moon and Lawrence pesta all of
whom just got memberships on my website
putting us at 62. folks I believe we can
get to 100. I believe we can
but not everybody necessarily but now
why isn't latest subscription showing up
here
oh I've got to bring it up
there it is there it is there it is we
always want the latest subscription
there beautiful
um okay
sure please ask pillow what he ordered
at Hardee's when the FBI raided him
yeah
or were you going to order at Hardee's
the day of the FBI raid that's a good
question
that's a good question
favorite sir cheers Mars
um no just stopping by I wanted to ask
if you are planning to act Mike pillow
on Tuesday
whether he still believes that Trump is
going to be reinstated
um it's been two years now yeah that's a
good question do you believe Trump will
be reinstated before January 2025 which
is when the next Presidential winner
will be inaugurated that's a good
question uh if you're just joining us
Mike pillow is going to be on the show
on Tuesday unless he uh cancels
um yeah I'll ask yeah like who is the
current president that's just like a
standard gut check at this point with
these guys
uh I will ask that
I will ask that
David will you finally relaunch an
omnipass account I mean you're a finance
guy you should know it's always a good
idea to diversify your income streams
right so where's the only fans man
yeah
right
that's uh
that's good okay
hi this is Melody I'm the new subscriber
to subscribe today uh my partner and I
were wondering how you managed to stay
so calm while you're watching things
like this very calm commentary we do
enjoy it but I'm usually the one like
flipping out and screaming at the TV I
even said my blood pressure went up
during the last Trump rally so what's
your secret to staying home yeah so
there's a couple different things here
um one is desensitization
okay one is desensitization the other is
just kind of an understanding let's see
if I can do this so there's this thing
from like stoic philosophy where let's
see if I can draw oh that's not how can
I draw a circle with this thing oh here
we go circles so you've got like if you
imagine these circles there's like
um
let's see if I can do this
oh man I don't know I'm gonna have to
draw them free hand oh God and this is
like not thick enough
let's go like this
okay so like this is the stuff you can
control
right
and then like this is the stuff you have
some control over in the second Circle
and then like all this stuff you have no
control over like this is all the stuff
so I try to like Focus most of my energy
in the middle too that the inner two
circles so like I can't control that all
these nuts exist I can't control that
people still think Trump's like a normal
person or all this stuff what I can
control is like am I voting
um
am I doing everything I can to inform
others about the insanity you know what
and I try to keep
out of my head the stuff I can't control
to a certain degree and so that is
useful in general like as a thing to
think about where I have direct
influence exactly
exactly and also I'm completely
desensitized like let's listen to
Marjorie Taylor green and watch me
remain completely calm despite the fact
that she should probably be locked up in
an insane asylum I'm not saying oh put
her in prison to probably the road out
there we can't see it from the stage but
that's that is amazing it looks like
people are fired up this is on a Sunday
afternoon it's 90 degrees out here the
sun these people aren't going anywhere
until president Trump walks off the
stage oh no actually sometimes they
start leaving while Trump is speaking
when they realize how boring it is he's
here he's traveling the country
supporting great candidates like Carrie
Lake and Blake Masters and Mark fincham
and everybody else and so no these
people are here because they love
president Trump they love his policy
well let's talk about it they love our
country they do love a country I said
this earlier and I want to get your
thoughts on this and you said this
President Trump is the leader of the
conservative party it is yeah there's
nothing conservative not even remotely
conservative about it that's the Wild
Thing
uh Kim says she left a better voicemail
okay we got a lot of voicemails dumping
in but we may get to it
uh Michael meant to type bad faith while
we're at it anyone promoting election
disinformation should also be Auto
banned zero nonsense zero tolerance for
that nonsense three years on it's not a
both sides game well said Michael
very much well said
um
voicemail about Kanye
hey David so um I was wondering what
this Kanye West thing
him and Ice Cube always have this uh
thing where they say like they're the
real Jews they like I hear this
you know slipped into things and Kanye
um
you've heard this and I know it's like
some weird story whatever but
um can you explain that what what's the
deal with that so listen I don't know if
this is what Kanye is referring to but
oftentimes when black folks say they are
the real Jews they're talking about this
I believe it's like the 12 lost tribes
it's a black Israelite thing and when I
would be when I would use the subway in
New York City I haven't been on the
subway since the start of the pandemic
but when I used to sometimes I would
come out of the subway and there would
be there would be the black Israelites
there handing out you know literature
for lack of a better term
um and yeah that's my understanding of
what
that's my guess although I don't know
exactly what Kanye meant by it but
usually when black folks talk about
we're the real Jews that's what they're
talking about
uh the Lost tribes
uh 12 tribes black Israelites Etc
um Trump bragging about January 6 crowd
size last night is so Twisted it's hard
to believe this is our reality I haven't
seen anything from last night's rally
but I will in time for the Tuesday show
David sir as a messy fan do you have
strong negative feelings for Cristiano
Ronaldo no I don't care about him he's
he doesn't bother me one bit
not one bit
uh yeah thanks to Joshua Sonnenberg for
signing up at joinpakman.com you were
new member number 63. okay let me see if
I can figure this out our goal is 100
new members today and we're at 63.
that's like is that like halfway roughly
we're roughly halfway there right 63 out
of 100 is like
50 between 50 and percent and two-thirds
or something
am I close
oh 63 how did you do that
63 percent
wow
you know what's funny and it's actually
said when I do this I will get 10 emails
and people will go David you know when
you are uh when you're dividing by a
hundred the number is the percentage
oh
oh okay I didn't I didn't know that
that's useful that's very useful
sir David love what you do hi from
Australia great to hear from our friends
in Australia always always always a
couple other voicemails coming in hey
David
um
Sandra here in San Diego
um I've lived in Mesa Arizona when I
went there with the Air Force back in
the late 70s so anyway we met the show
Ellsworth Road a few minutes ago and
Ellsworth was where we had a small
Air Force Base and it was orange groves
and dairy farms
so this is way out from Mesa but I
thought you'd enjoyed that take care
love the show bye oh I like her that was
that's I don't know why that's even so I
guess it's funny to make all these
trumpets drive out to like you know dirt
in the middle of nowhere to watch the
Trump speech uh I like that
let's see what else we've got here
hey David I was curious if uh pillow
knows what the third element of the
Serenity Prayer is hmm thank you
all right
we can see about getting into that David
Josh from La
um
uh F pillow which uh which plain Donald
Trump will be flying in uh or or you or
that's a better way to ask it would be
ask him why
Donald Trump doesn't have his Trump
Force One Flame anymore oh I don't think
he has any idea about that
it looks like we are maybe getting close
to Trump speaking
uh
uh evil vacuum says sir would you where
would you recommend an American look to
emigrate if socialized medicine is
important to them well the question is
does it have to be a place it's actually
easy to go
if it's just all theoretical there are
so many options I mean the northern
European countries are a great option
Germany has a good system
Spain has a good sister Switzerland not
all of these are
strictly speaking socialized there's a
combination of different systems in a
lot of these countries but there's no
shortage of options the the problem is
it's difficult to move to a lot of those
places who is this guy goes all the way
up to the Four Corners even comes down
south of Phoenix into Pinal County oh
wow okay so if you're in any of those
of those go to what is the website again
Eli for arizona.com okay check it out
doors yes ma'am that's fantastic
congratulations you also have an amazing
background can you tell us a little bit
about your story and where you've come
from yeah there's an Undertaker still a
small business owner we're featured on
Shark Tank
um I'm a dad I'm a father I'm a
Christian and I love this country and
I'm tired of watching it be destroyed I
like this man for you where do you see
uh what do you think needs to be some of
the first things done in Congress to
help the people of Arizona right so I
think the border is probably number one
right up there with the economy this
these folks are killing people out there
with you know their foolish ideas and
I'm also really uh disappointed to see
so so much influence with radical
Marxism socialism communism and it just
I never thought Christina I would live
in this country it's funny because it's
like
socialism Marxism and communism are
three different things for there to be a
bunch of each of the three there would
have to be like at least a dozen
prominent socialist marxists and
Communists in power and there are like
none what uh what's happening now
[Music]
okay they're playing a propaganda video
now uh here's the uh Huckabee thing
again all right
um a couple of final thank yous folks
get in before Trump comes out Cameron
Underhill just signed up on my website
also want to say thanks to Jason
sickmeyer for gifting another membership
puts us at 65 over on Twitch
uh nothing over on Twitch nothing but
that's okay still appreciate everybody
there a couple super uh voicemails
coming in
stream one of these Trump rallies it
just reinforces mine and my partner's
decision to move out of the U.S and to
New Zealand
Shalom yeah well glad it's helping you
for some reason oh look at this
look at this it's everything in his path
because every once in a while wow this
is truly a cult huh
just refresh to make sure we're live
and we want 1080p
wow this is really really really
cult-like like extra cult like today
um
thanks to S Prez for gifting 20 more
subscriptions
huge gift now one thousand
eight hundred
and thirty five gifted subscriptions for
S press
also thank you to Ray Nera for the
twitch Prime subscription number 86
Donald Trump is just moments away from
delivering unhinged lies to a crowd that
quite frankly doesn't seem able to tell
the difference nor are they interested
in telling the difference there is Trump
I think
uh this by the way we are in 1080P the
pixelation is coming through on the
right side broadcasting stream it is not
something I am able to correct meanwhile
it does not seem that even Newsmax is
covering this rally which would really
be a new low for Trump uh but maybe they
will switch to it let's listen
[Applause]
oh God I really can't deal with that
song at this point it's it's god-awful
god-awful
quite frankly thanks to Rude Boy for the
twitch Prime subscription folks we might
get to a hundred right as Donald Trump
utters his first lie Trump going with
the no tie look today my prediction
Trump complains about the weather
and cuts the speech relatively short
because of the the heat that's my
prediction
um
well if Newsmax is no longer even taking
Trump's speeches then you know something
is going very very wrong that would be a
significant change
uh they were sort of like the last
holdout in a sense Beyond uh right side
broadcasting but if they are not even
covering it it would really be
it's almost like sad for him I guess I
don't know
depends what you consider good or bad
you would kind of like polish like me uh
I may look polish but I am not polish I
am I am an Ashkenazi Jew Whitney I've
got to get away from that because it's a
bit weaponized thanks to leonelda Blake
for the sign up on my website leonelda
you were new member number 88 today and
I very much appreciate it let's listen
it's still they're still cranking the
music
um
these rallies are really really horrible
thanks to phaedris for the twitch Prime
subscription number 89.
all right guys in the chat how long
until he complains about the heat how
long until he's visibly sweating
[Applause]
I wish those cameras the fake news I
wish look at all of them up there I wish
I wish they'd turn around and show the
crowd they never like to do it that goes
back as far as the eye can see and I
even see people wait there's a couple
thousand people there that's it
I just want to thank you and say hello
Mesa and
hello Phoenix we love Phoenix so we love
the great state of Arizona has been
really good it's been we want it big and
we want it big a second time the second
time they didn't exactly give us a good
count but that's being worked on Biden
won Sam thank you very much for being
here the great Uncle Sam
it's wonderful to be back in Arizona
with thousands of proud hard-working
American Patriots you are amazing people
this is a fantastic state
30 days from now the people of Arizona
are going to fire your radical and
highly incompetent Senator Mark Kelly's
grossly head company
and you're going to sin desperately
needed Blake Master where's Blake
where is Blake
Blake Masters Kelly is currently winning
by four points but it's not exactly a
huge margin that's what you need and
you're going to make an incredible woman
incredible Carrie like your next
Governor she's an incredible woman
incredible person
look at the crowd that you drew Carrie
they're here for you and Blake and all
of the Republicans you're going to elect
a truly amazing America First Republican
group of we're going to do a slate
straight up and down we don't want crime
we want a strong military we want low
taxes we want great education
and we're going to end the crazy Nancy
Pelosi's political career once and for
all
Newsmax not even covering this
under Biden Pelosi Schumer and the
radical democrat congress gasoline
prices Congratulations by the way in
Arizona are up 86 in a very short period
of time and they're going higher
you know they're trying to take our
strategic reserves that we built up so
beautifully and they're right now
depleted the lowest they've been in many
many decades nobody remembers them all
to get your gasoline prices down before
an election the day after the election
you're going to be like a rocket ship
you know that it's terrible inflation is
costing the typical Arizona Family
almost one thousand dollars a month
think of that over eleven thousand
dollars a year household wealth has seen
its largest drop ever recorded ever in
the history of our country your border
has been
completely obliterated the cartels and
human traffickers have seen their income
Skyrocket since I left
you're beautiful border they've seen it
skyrocketed 2 000 carry 2 500 percent
that's what they're making two thousand
five hundred percent more than when we
were in charge you know we had the
safest Border in the history of our
country now we have the worst border I
think anywhere in the world
I don't think any third world country
would allow to happen what's happened
here millions and millions of illegal
aliens are coming unvetted and unchecked
into your communities from over
140 different countries last month 140
most people don't know they have that
many countries
most people do actually I said an
all-time homicide record and Nationwide
the number of Hispanic murder victims is
up over 50 percent
there's only one way to end this
nightmare this madness if you want the
decline and fall of America then you
must vote radical left Democrat if you
want to see this country continue
there's never been a time where our
country is so embarrassed
it's just a disgrace what's happened do
you want to see that go vote them all
polling has opinion of the United States
stronger today than when Trump was
President there is no serious poll that
shows the reputation of the U.S is worse
now than when Trump was in dream
we were talking about
[Music]
[Applause]
and as bad as things are today if the
radical Democrats keep their grip on the
House and Senate your finances your
family your community and your country
will never ever be able to recover
you're not going to recover from this
Mark Kelly and the Democratic extremists
will flood the country with tens of
millions more illegal aliens
Mark Kelly is very Centrist things like
Mass amnesty
they want to give illegal aliens welfare
more welfare than American citizens get
more help than we give to our great
veterans they want to give free health
care I don't think anybody here has free
health care anybody have free health
care
and the right to vote Farm it's like
they're almost proud that that we don't
have it they're weird that we give to
our military more than we give to
American citizens that have been
outstanding and have worked so hard for
our country they'll abolish the
filibuster pack the Supreme Court put
left-wing Federal bureaucrats in charge
of corrupting every single election like
they've been doing gut the military
destroy our veterans loot the treasury
mutilate our children with gender
insanity and turn America into a third
world country and that's what's
happening
he's jumping into the overtly
transphobic part of the speech much
earlier today
[Applause]
delivering a clean sweep of every
Statewide office for the Republican
party right most of them are here and
they're not here they're here
you can prove that Arizona is still a
red State and you are your proud Red
State
[Music]
you know I came here we did three
rallies 42 000 44 000 and 46 000. he
came he did one rally he couldn't fill
up eight circles he put the Press he put
the fake news media that is a lot of
media Blake
Carrie look at all of them
but once we get critical of them you'll
see the cameras turn off and they'll
start to head out they never turn them
off hopefully that'll be quickly
if we do not defeat the radical
Democrats in this election the maniacs
and the lunatics will be totally out of
control not that they're not already
hello everybody look at the look at that
group of people
oh I see I haven't seen this to you
people all have chairs who are these big
shots over they all have checked look at
them
see I think they should move the media
back about 200 yards and let everybody
that's what I would do
I have to scold my people I have to
scold my people if you don't mind will
you please from now on move the media
back they have good telescopic cameras
it won't matter give me a break
because they blocked the view all these
people but the good news is you'll never
see it because they never want to show
the crowds they never ever ever but you
know what you hear by the way they
showed the crowd for hours it's not very
big stations right now including we want
to thank Newsmax they've been great
they've all been right side isn't
covering it oh that's freaking brilliant
Trump is thanking Newsmax Newsmax seems
to be showing stand-up comedy of Mike
Huckabee and Trump thanked them that's
just the best guys wow my millions and
millions of people before our very eyes
Biden and his left-wing handlers are
turning America into a police state
after ignoring violent attacks on
pro-life clinics dividend thanks to
Newsmax they're showing Huckabee life
activists you see it happening and you
see it happening nightly although for
the most part they don't want to report
it first they arrested the Catholic
father of seven that you read about two
weeks ago and then this week they
arrested pro-life grandparents with guns
drawn many people going into this small
but well-kept and beautiful little house
many people FBI going in to take a
grandmother out of that house
putting them in jail and protesting
outside of abortion clinics and charging
them with crimes punishable by up to 11
years in prison 11 years
Blake you're gonna have to do something
about this Blake we got to do something
about this Kelly isn't doing a thing
about it Kelly doesn't even know what's
happening
and they're doing this to Peaceful
Patriots at numbers that have never been
seen before and they have the right of
free speech and this is free and really
you'd almost say it's free and Silent
speech they're not doing anything right
I wonder if Grandma did anything to get
herself arrested I'm just kind of
curious drug lords in fact I must say
drug lords are treated much better
nothing happens to them nothing happens
to antifa nothing happens to BLM but
look at what happens to Patriots
the Democrats are locking up their
political opponents spying on their
political Rivals silencing dissent and
using the full force of government law
enforcement and the media to try and
crush the greatest movement in the
history of America it's the greatest
movement
Mega it's called make America great
again when Biden got up with a bad
Sinister background and he talked about
how bad Maga was I said does anybody
want to ask him if he understands what
that means Mega it means make America
great again
oh every freedom-loving America needs to
understand the time to stand up right
now we have to stand up it's going to be
too late we've got to stop this growing
tyranny starting with the Earth
shattering victory that you're going to
have on November 8th you have to go out
and ideally vote ideally vote on
November 8th you know the mail-in
ballots or sometimes I will say things
like the fake mail-in balance but I
don't want to say that because that's so
controversial
but the mail-in ballots
are just not as good as being out there
on November 8th you know that Carrie get
out and vote on November 8th it's harder
for them to cheat they cheat
they cheat
how to you know they say it's a 50 50
parties right so they're against God
they're against guns they're against
voter ID voter ID why are they against
voter ID they're against confirmation
that you happen to be a citizen of the
United States in other words you can't
confirm when you vote they think that's
horrible uh it's crazy what they're
getting away with the only way
evil will triumphs for good men and
women is when they do nothing you know
that and these are good people they do
nothing I think they feel they're lost
we can't be lost we can't be lost we
don't have time so no matter what these
left-wing radicals try next no matter
what they do to us we have to keep on
going we have to keep on fighting
because we're on a mission to restore
our nation back to Greatness
and you don't hear about greatness
anymore all you hear about is
investigations every investigation I've
been investigated because he hasn't done
anything great and he's potentially
committed a lot of crimes honest person
in history
he said if they looked at me for more
than two days that's the end of my
business they've been after me for close
to seven years
for six straight years
these witch hunts have been in full
force witch hunts hoaxes and abuses have
been coming at us at a fast and furious
Pace no be you don't even have time to
recover you beat them and then you have
to you take a breath and then they hit
you again these are dishonest people
these are people that don't love our
country they're people that don't love
our country first we learned
they spotted my campaign how do you
think it would be let's go back to
Barack Hussein Obama how do you think it
would be if we as Republicans spied
on his campaign do you think
and and they don't want to do it well
yeah they spied you know they spied on
the campaign and we caught them
so let's see what's all going to happen
outside of my campaign then they lied to
Congress
many many times lied to Congress and
then they lied to the fisa court and
created a fake dossier remember the
dossier how would you like to be me and
go home to my great
first lady and say first lady
I want to tell you what they said in the
dossier and she said sir and that would
not work out too well for most of you
men in the audience right
and then it turned out to be a total
fake
and one thing I will say about her she
said
I don't believe it I said I said oh I'm
glad about that I'm very happy no but
how about the things you know the things
they said Uncle Sam you saw that right
they said things all fake all fake made
up by bad people and it was done and
paid for by crooked Hillary Clinton the
Democrat National Committee in the
Democrat Party in conjunction
in conjunction with Russia they said
Russia Russia Russia about me and they
were working with Russia this could only
happen to Trump
and yet after all that these same people
came after me so they spy in my campaign
and then they come after Trump
Republicans Russia Russia Russia Ukraine
Ukraine Ukraine and then it was the
Mueller Witch Hunt where the conclusion
yeah he's already sweaty so we may
benefit from the heat in Arizona
insofar As Trump may keep this very
short because he's already got it's
almost like
drips and droplets on his forehead and
he couldn't
and then it was after that impeachment
hoax number remember this impeachment
perfect phone call just did you guys re
that was just a glitch I don't know if
you saw that everybody was always be
with it impeachment hoax number one
of the Biden family corruption story
remember the laptop from hell
as Russian disinformation by the FBI in
cooperation with Facebook and the media
which they all knew wasn't true they
knew it it wasn't true but they wanted
to censor it they wanted to keep it
quiet until after the election something
about these two they don't seem to be
having a great time so far in the polls
we didn't need
17 points we didn't need one point all
we needed was an honest election we
didn't need anything
and now it's the unselect committee of
political hacks and thugs
and that's a scam and it's also
really appalling misconduct by the
racist and incompetent New York State
Attorney General
she's a racist and she's incompetent her
name is Leticia peek-a-boo James who's
presiding over record numbers of murders
rapes drug deals and every other form of
crime
in our once great New York State not
great anymore people of fleeing New York
because of crime
but only spends her time in getting
elected let's go after Trump oh you saw
the clip let's go after Trump maybe I
can get election or nothing about me
never heard of her she ran for governor
and failed badly she got almost nothing
now she's running again for attorney
general with a record of massive crime
the likes of which New York state has
never seen before she's down in the
polls losing to a strong crime fighter
that's what we need is a strong
Republican crime fighter who would ever
want
to vote for somebody like her so corrupt
and so bad on violent crime we need
people that are going to fight crime we
need a safe country again
peekaboo wants to defund the police
hates the people of law enforcement and
will never do it I've still not gotten a
clear answer on why he refers to Leticia
James as peekaboo someone told me that
it's a way of using the racist term
[ __ ] without saying it where he says
peekaboo which is similar
I I'm not sure I genuinely don't know
what that's about
that was made about election and
tickle today about a
call up the secretary said about
election Integrity they say oh that's
such a terrible thing no it's called
free speech
and despite the fact that Atlanta on a
per capita basis has more murders and
crimes than any other city in the
country including Chicago nobody knows
that and yet they're looking at a phone
call that I made which was absolutely
perfect about election integrity that's
what they're spending their money and
their time on and nobody is being taken
care of and Atlanta is a crime city like
just about no other city in the world
it is gone strictly third world Atlanta
has all of these local democrat-run
cases are being directed by Washington I
have no doubt about it no evidence we
have a weaponized Department no doubt
and no evidence important to note of
course the break-in of my home
remember they didn't break in they had a
search warrant signed off on by the FBI
director attorney general and the judge
just like impeachment talks number one
impeachment Oaks number two we have to
the document hoax case what we could
call it the warehouse case because many
other presidents stored their millions
of pages of stuff in unsecured
warehouses some of them without
front doors that worked properly just
look they had only a back door then it's
like well is that the front door then I
don't know it did beautifully all they'd
need to do is leave office and they get
treated beautifully they've been given
the time needed and complete deference
when it came to their documents into
their papers there was no criminality
there was no oh we're gonna get him
we're gonna get him and the people of
the same people that have been working
on this for six years Barack Hussein
Obama moved more than 20 truckloads over
33 million pages of documents both
classified and unclassified to a poorly
built and totally unsafe former
furniture store located in a rather bad
neighborhood in Chicago you know about
that right they just found that out what
do you think of that Carrie it's a
little double standard perhaps George W
bush or Rhino but that's okay
stored 68 million pages in a warehouse
in Texas think of that and oh excuse me
he lost 22 million White House emails
covering the Iraq invasion which was one
of the dumbest things that this country
has ever done one of the dumbest things
what did we get out of it other than
death
and a loss of massive numbers of great
great young people
what did we get out of it and we really
obliterated a big part of the world we
got nothing out of it they're still
looking for those 22 million pages Bill
Clinton took millions of documents from
the White House to a former car
dealership in Arkansas
I got classified recordings in a sock
did you know about that they say he left
the White House with recordings in his
sock and they found them in his sock
draw his socked raw and they didn't find
him he found him I guess
it is shock draw
which is the naira it's called lost an
entire hard drive full of information
from the Clinton White House I wonder
what that information was Bill Clinton
also lost the nuclear codes
and nobody complained Trump didn't lose
the nuclear codes I could tell you more
about nuclear codes I rebuilt our
nuclear Arsenal not that I wanted to but
because we had no time to do it when you
see what's going on right now I had to
do it and we'll end up in a war with the
incompetence and the way we're handling
this we'll end up in a world war Jimmy
Carter sent the nuclear codes to his dry
cleaner you know that right
and almost there's been nothing happened
though nobody said oh we're gonna get
him we're after we're going to prosecute
Jimmy Carter he said the nuclear goats
to his dry cleaner
and they never got him back they're
still looking for him but they're
looking you know how many years ago was
this and almost as bad Hillary deleted
33 000 emails under Congressional
subpoena
I said wash them and then pound
the phones with hammers making them
unrecognizable to the human eye
me by the way you know the Jimmy Carter
story like you know presidents don't do
their own laundry it is a true story
that there were once codes left in a
suit
that Jimmy Carter's staff had cleaned or
whatever but it's like you can't do
anything with the codes first of all
unless you have access to the weapons
but it also is like he's making it seem
like Jimmy Carter sent us you know
brought a suit to his local drive it's
it's such a crazy story because other
than that it was quite secure and there
was no security and they didn't have
these great Secret Service people who
are great by the way they're great they
don't get enough
they don't get enough
they don't get enough credit by contrast
I had a small number of boxes in storage
at Mar-A-Lago guarded by secret service
and my people and everybody I mean it's
safe when you look at
these other people what they did and the
FBI raided my home and violated my
fourth amendment rights and many other
rights and under the Sox decision this
is a very important decision that was
made to court the Sox decision because
again it had to do with Bill Clinton and
his socks
there is no crime you know there is no
crime it's not a crime
and they should give me immediately back
everything that they've taken from me
because it's mine it's mine it was also
planted by the FBI but he needs it back
into my house
but you know the good news is everyone
saw it
would you believe my poll numbers went
up
there are no polls as poll numbers I've
ever had I don't know
[Music]
I think I'm the only one where the FBI
breaks into your house probably
illegally in my opinion illegally and
your polls numbers go up that doesn't
happen to too many people Blake there
you go likewise under the presidential
record act everything should come back
well should come back and under the
presidential record act there is no
crime remember for weeks he claimed he
never had the stuff now he says it
should be given back to him immediately
period of time that's what we were doing
the National Archives put a trigger
warning on the Constitution of the
United States did you know that and the
Bill of Rights and other great documents
that we have in our country founding
documents considering them to be
dangerous they consider the Constitution
to be dangerous these are radical left
lunatics and they lose documents they
plant documents let's see is there a
book on nuclear destruction or the
building of a nuclear weapon cheaply
let's put that box let's put that book
in with Trump
no they plant documents I mean they have
a terrible reputation look at the kind
of things this is just a small part what
I've read
and who would want to be with them
we're safer in that Chinese restaurant
that we just mentioned to be honest when
will they investigate and prosecute Bill
Clinton Hillary Clinton George Bush and
look into what took place George Bush's
father which and the warehouse of
documents had by Barack Hussein Obama
and I don't think they'll do it and you
know what I don't think they should do
it I don't think they should do it but
the radical left thinks by doing all of
these Sinister and venomous things
they're making us weaker but actually
they are making us stronger and much
more unified than we've ever been before
we now have a two-tiered system of
justice and it's got to stop because the
people of our country are angry the
people of our country are very unhappy
with what's going on in fact the people
of our country are very sad they don't
like to see this what they want to do is
make America great again and to put
America first that's what they want to
do it's very simple
right and they want this radical left
charade that goes on endlessly for years
to stop many powerful influential people
tell me you must there is a two-tier
justice system it's just not the one he
thinks
bye
oh we lost contact and frankly for
violating your own civil rights and
Liberties and it's you know a lot of
Truth to that who the hell lives like
this
they've been doing this to me for years
ever since I came down the golden
escalator and Trump Tower no other
president has ever been treated like
this
and I'm not complaining because you know
what I'm doing a great job for the
people of he's not complaining guys I
mean other than this rally and every
other rally
foreign
that they may actually be charging
Hunter Biden remember remember the
where's Hunter where's Hunter charge him
I don't care half a million dollars of
painting
you know great artists come into the
White House because they're supposed to
be painting my picture for the White
House it's funny if Trump gets indicted
these people are gonna Riot if they
charge Hunter I'd be like oh I mean
there must be evidence he committed a
crime I don't know I mean the fine
charge right I don't care guys I think
the government pays I'll pay but how
much and it's very little money actually
and then you hear Hunter Biden gets 500
000 to take a can of paint and throw it
against a piece of canvas but not do it
himself you know as other people do what
I imagine
but they may actually be charging Hunter
Biden with very minor charges relative
to crimes committed and that's really up
to them
but are they actually doing this charade
to continue targeting me and our
movement it sounds to me like they're
doing it so they could say well you know
we're treating everyone fairly now
they're not they're not treating us
fairly and they have to be very careful
because it can come around you know it
can come around and snip them they have
to be very very careful what they're
doing they're playing a game that's
never been played to this extent in our
country they're coming after me because
I fight for you and I fight for American
because we are leading big in every
single poll and winning all across our
country both against Republicans and
against Democrats who are leading
against everybody thank you thank you
what's he talking about anybody know
we're leading by numbers that nobody's
ever seen before because
Republicans so we got some Republicans
that say oh we want to run
you let him run who the hell cares we're
leading by so much and uh it's
incredible with all of this what they're
trying to do is take us out so that we
can't represent you if we decide to do
that but we'll be making a decision very
soon I think everyone's going to be
happy I really do
right the radical left
is no longer about socialism it's about
communism we've skipped over socialism I
think and that's where our country is
headed and I predicted this would happen
a long time ago when I felt it I felt it
in my blown blood I just felt it in my
bones and blood
yeah
are in for a period of time because we
have people that truly either they hate
our country they are competent look they
are confident he felt it in his blowns
that's something you know Shifty shift
Shifty Adam Chef
Shifty Adams you I mean I tell the story
every once in a while I have a son who's
a very good young man he's been through
hell he's 40 something with all these
investigations he thought he was going
to just help the country Don Jr does
anyone know Don Jr
so it's now come out that the fake
dossier the dossier was a total uh put
up fake job done by the Democrats and
Hillary right DNC in conjunction with
Russia so it's now a fake in fact the
times admitted it the Washington Post
admitted it even stupid CNN nobody
watches them anymore because they have
no ratings but they a lot of great 44
year old Don Jr is a fine kid
but everybody now says it was a fake
and Adam Schiff was in on it but I see
Adam Sheriff a few years ago come out to
the microphone just like this now think
of this he helped devise a fake scheme
so he has a fake scheme and he comes out
to the microphone and he knows it's a
lie and he said
I have just witnessed horrible horrible
events in a horrible document and I
believe Donald Trump Jr will be serving
time in prison in the very near future
now think of this how bad are you when
you tell somebody anybody I don't care
president or not president somebody's
son is going to go to jail and you know
it's a hoax you know it's fake Uncle Sam
do you agree with that now think of it
you know it's a hoax and he's saying
that my son is going to jail on
something these are bad people these are
sick degenerates if the Democrats win
the Communists win and soon they will
send their thugs their criminals their
angry left-wing prosecutors and their 87
000 new IRS agents who are allowed to
carry guns you know that right almost
all of them are just replacing retiring
agents it's really it's like a non-story
our Second Amendment no guns nobody has
nobody can have guns and yet 87 as an
IRS agents are allowed to have guns
explain that one if Republicans win the
Communists lose the globalists lose the
Deep State bureaucrats lose the Silicon
Valley censors lose the corrupt fake
news media bosses lose and the Rhinos
lose back in five but America wins and
wins big and that's the only thing that
will matter
the only thing that will matter
this election is your chance to send a
strong message to all of the Arrogant
left-wing radicals who want to dictate
what you can say and what you can think
and how you are supposed to lead your
lives with your families with your vote
you can humiliate Joe Biden not that he
hasn't been humiliated enough
the media and the corrupt Democrat
machine and you can declare that America
will always remain a free and fair
country
you can take the five worst Presidents
in American history and put them
together and they would not have done
the damage Joe Biden has done to our
nation in less than two short years
think of it look at look at what's
happened we're like a totally different
country than we were two years ago two
years ago we were respected by the world
today we're a joke when Biden hears me
speak he knows he can't fight back in
any other way than to try and get me
through the prosecutors or some weird
Act
except I'm innocent it's always good to
be innocent right because if I wasn't I
would have been out of here years ago
it's been going on for years
in fact my son I said the other night I
have a wonderful son Eric I think he's
received more subpoenas from the United
States Congress than any human being in
the history of
the world is a great guy he's wants to
just do his job and every day every week
every month he gets hit with a subpoena
from Schiff and from Nancy Pelosi is
crooked as hell look at her stocks I
mean she did better than Warren Buffett
I don't know about her husband I don't
know who the hell is running that deal
but how and now she doesn't want to
change it where they're allowed to get
inside information Joe Biden can't speak
clearly he can't think clearly so he
tells law enforcement you got to do
something about this guy Trump he's
killing me take a look at this you'll
see just take a look you're not even
going to believe how would you say
you're would you say your mental focus
is
was focused
I say it's I think it's I I haven't look
Ed I think it's a right for people that
bad I can't care
through International numbers of
pressure guys
oh I just said that America is a nation
that can be defined in a single word
thousand foot
corn pop was a bad dude and he ran a
bunch of bad boys wait wait wait all men
and women created by that go you know
this you know the thing it holds near
and dear to you that you uh
um like to be able to
anyway
we went for two reasons
one
two
[Music]
come on man
my my uh the guy who runs that outfit
over there
I've had a couple
[Music]
with the nature
not
representative Jackie are you here
where's Jackie I don't think she she was
going to be here
um uh um what am I doing here but Tucker
yeah
I got hairy legs that turn that that
that that thank you for tolerance for
listening to me
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
during the course of four great years
despite all of these witch hunts we did
so much but one of the things that I got
to learn a lot about were the leadership
of other countries president XI all of
the different leaders Putin all of them
and you go one by one step by step the
Crone of France can name every single
one of them I got mostly friendly with
them some of them didn't like me because
I stopped them from taking advantage of
our country which almost all of them
were doing
so they wouldn't like me
I know in Germany they said we like
Obama better they should they robbed us
black they should but one thing we
learned is they're all at the top of
their game mentally they're at the top
of their game president XI of China you
there's nobody in Hollywood that could
imitate him that could play the role of
presidency there's nobody there's no
actor he's a smart tough
brilliant people in most cases but
they're all at the top of the game and
the fake news media doesn't like when I
use the word brilliant how can you say
that about President XI well he's the
head of 1.5 million people Carrie I'd
say he pretty smart guy what'd you say
and by the way he has no drug problem
you know that right you know why quick
trial
because they they give the death penalty
to people that are selling drugs but I
got to meet and they're dealing with
this gentleman and they don't know what
the hell is going on
under my leadership we had for the first
time American Energy Independence and
even energy dominance we were going to
be
bigger than think of it Russia and Saudi
Arabia combined in a very short period
of time we would be right now supplying
oil to Europe you wouldn't have a war
number one the war was never going to
happen anyway with me there but just the
oil we would have been down at forty
dollars thirty five maybe thirty dollars
a barrel you were at a dollar eighty
cents
in fact I had it down for a little while
to a dollar fifty we had to get it a
little up we had it we had to let the
oil company survive but you were down to
a dollar eighty seven a gallon and now
you're way over five dollars think of it
way way over and that's with the
artificial stimulus of the Strategic
Reserve which is going away one day
after the election's over so I just say
that these were at 390 right now
a person and people that aren't now he's
surrounded by vicious smart people don't
underestimate I don't even believe that
he's the one necessarily that's causing
these problems he is surrounded by
vicious very smart people with a
different ideology than the people in
this office than the people in your
great state and we're going to have to
be very smart and very strong because
that's not what's doing it people are
pulling strings and it's very sad to
watch nobody thought this could happen
in our country and it all happened
because of a rigged and stolen election
now Biden is begging and pleading with
OPEC but instead of increasing
production they're cutting it did you
see the other day they cut that's going
to drive gasoline prices up much higher
in your electric and everything else we
gave you the largest tax cuts and
regulation Cuts in American history on
the other hand the radical Democrat
Congress has passed one of the largest
tax hikes in American history
but they were still unable to pass any
legislation which affected our tax cuts
because they couldn't do it they
couldn't get it through they would have
but it still Remains the Trump tax cuts
they have not been able to do anything
about it under the Trump Administration
we had the greatest economy of the
history of the world with no inflation
Biden and the democrat congress created
the worst inflation in over 50 years
we're right now at 9.1 percent that it's
going to go a lot higher and the worst
two years of a presidency in history I
rebuilt our military including our
nuclear capability and the creation of
space force first time that's been done
in 78 years
you heard of a thing called Air Force
not since Air Force and space Force
turned out to be very very important
indeed we're now leading in space
because of what we did was winning again
and China and Russian owned space
until I came along and now we're leading
in space and that's going to end up
being one of the most important of all
they surrendered our strength and our
our dignity
and turned Afghanistan into the single
greatest humiliation our country has
ever had I believe that the way we got
out not of getting out I was getting out
to I would have done it on a similar
schedule but with strength and with with
what you have to get the way you leave
properly are you guys aware that we had
zero alien invasions from outer space
under Trump
think about that no the fake news media
certainly won't tell you that after the
war in Ukraine or we will end up in
World War III and there will never be
a war like this we will never have had a
war like this and that's all because of
stupid people that don't have a clue and
it's also because of the kind of
Weaponry that's available today you we
never had weapons like this the
destructive capability of weapons modern
weapons I know more about it than
anybody because of the fact that I
rebuilt our military
you could just look at Russia and say
see when you talk about going to war
it's not as easy as people think it's
just not as easy who would have thought
that would have happened going to war is
tough but remember he's still got
a second layer and it's a very powerful
layer
and we have to be very smart and very
Nimble we have to know what to say what
to do and looks like folks are starting
to head out here's one lady sort of
trying to shuffle her way out this is a
theme at Trump rallies this is roughly
the point at which people do start to
leave and there's often videos of people
just flowing flowing out and that woman
seemingly bothering some of the other
folks you'll start to see folks trickle
out now it's a real possibility and two
years ago it wasn't even thought of
I withdrew from the disastrous Iran
nuclear deal and opposed the toughest
Newsmax still not covering this
apparently it's like an evening look at
this sepi Paterno who just became
Italy's oldest college graduate and for
the second time two years ago really
cool show anyway that's what they're
showing instead of the Trump rally and
China didn't buy oil I told president
she don't buy oil don't buy you buy oil
we're not going to do any business with
China and he didn't buy any oil as we
speak the people of Iran are bravely
protesting against their corrupt and
brutal regime courageously facing down
violence persecution jail torture and
even death and we are with you all I
want you to know that on behalf of
everybody here and everybody period we
are with them
two years ago we had the strongest
Border in the history of our country
and now we have exactly the opposite in
August illegal border crossings in
Arizona we're up
471 remember the impossibility of those
figures
if you're catching people
You could argue successful Crossings are
down right like you could turn around
and go we have the most tight border
because look at all the people we're
catching when you don't catch them it's
because people are getting through all
these things even when the numbers are
true they don't necessarily prove the
thing Trump thinks they prove Because by
the tens of thousands we got rid of Isis
we got rid of we did and by the way we
defeated Isis in the Middle East right
nobody wants to talk about that
we defeated Isis we defeated al-baghdadi
didn't we remember Conan Conan the dog
he got more credit than I did for
defeating Isis Conan what about him he
deserves that he was a brave dog
we built hundreds of miles of Water
World despite two and a half years of
democrat-inspired lawsuits to stop it
but I won all of them over 11 lawsuits
we completely finished our original wall
plan then we added much more wool and
almost got that finished it would have
been done in three weeks that's all it
would have taken and they didn't want to
do the job they didn't want that's when
I said there's something wrong here
something is wrong in short the election
took place it was a disaster for our
country and we are suffering the results
of that election I ran twice I won twice
and I did much better the second time
than I did the first getting Millions
more votes in 220. then we got in 2016.
220.
we got many more
we got many more votes in the last
election many many
and we got more votes than any sitting
president in the history
of our country by far you know but not
more than any candidate that's for sure
visiting president in history and now we
may just have to do it again so stay
tuned because we're not going to let our
country die not letting our country die
[Music]
[Applause]
but we did much better in 2020 you know
the New York Times came and they were
talking to me what was the difference
between
2016 and 2020 I said well the difference
was that we did much better in 2020 oh
you did really you think they didn't
understand that now we got millions more
votes like 12 million or something in
220 BC they did it Irving wall
I love that jacket I'm gonna wear that
jacket someday oh no the only difference
is we didn't use brick we used steel
because it's stronger and you can see
through we need to see through we
listened to the border patrol but first
we have to win a historic Victory that's
the wall that can be defeated with a
hundred bucks worth of stuff from Home
Depot for Republican Congress is to stop
that's what it is it's like a military
invasion in many ways it's worse because
with military you can stop them with
Force these people are coming through
totally unencumbered but we have to stop
The Invasion on our Southern Border in
August an illegal alien criminal was
sentenced for walking into a convenience
store right here in Mason
taking out his gun killing 21 year old
clerk a wonderful young man because he
wanted a pack of cigarettes
in New Mexico an illegal alien criminal
out of jail on unsecured Bond was
charged with decapitating a man
mutilating his body and kicking his head
around a field as though it were soccer
ball it was a soccer ball in a public
park guys
you know who was president when that
happened
Trump
these lurid stories where he says
someone was just sentenced
sometimes it's for a crime that took
place while Trump was President by the
president of the national border patrol
Council a great gentleman a tough man he
was with me from the beginning I'm not
even sure he was allowed to be but he
was
because he knows what we need in this
country is border safety and border
security his name is Brandon Judd
Brandon where is Brandon
where's Brandon
I love this guy
I love come here Brandon just fast come
on we're not here for Brandon but get up
here come on
and we have another great guy he's
always been so helpful along with all of
Brandon's people Tom Holman have you
ever seen any Central Casting
where's Tom I love Tom Holman
what a job you put these guys in charge
you'll have it solved very quickly say a
few words hello people were starting to
come whoa veggie what can we say
about Donald Trump that hasn't already
been said oh God best president in our
history in our history
45-year lows illegal immigration was
dropped to 45 year lows we were able to
go after the criminal cartels we were
able to drop the drugs that were coming
into the United States under this
President more than we ever had
Republican Democrat it didn't matter
this President did more it kind of did
matter save your children your children
your grandchildren they than anybody
else
and yet
and yet he's constantly constantly and
yet he lost to a guy who campaigned from
his basement by eight million votes how
humiliating yeah exactly look we got
some great people please stand up all my
guys back there
art Del Cueto right there and let me
tell you the president is here
campaigning the president is Biden's
there for some great people Carrie Lake
gotta win have to win
she's got to
yeah exactly Blake Masters he has to win
Abe Abe has to win
and Mark has to has to win but more
importantly
we need this guy to run
2024
2024 will be the greatest the greatest
year in politics ever present thank you
very much and we will bend men
wow wow
super strong am I glad I asked him to
come up that was that was very good
thank you Brandon thank you to all the
folks that are with you thank you very
much great job you do they do such a
great job and that includes ice ice is
so incredible that tough
they're great great people ice also and
law enforcement period
if we're going to make America great
again we have to make America safe again
it's very simple Brendan understands
that Tom Holman understands that under
the radical left Democrats our country
has become a cesspool of crime much of
the crime wave is caused by drug dealers
who during the course of their lives
will kill an average of 500 Americans
citizens one person will kill on average
during his or her lifetime 500 people so
I'm calling for the death penalty for
drug dealers in human traffickers there
you go
which will upon its passage reduce drug
distribution and crime
by more than 75 percent of its
meaningful if it's a meaningful bill
75 down in one day it'll end I tell the
story about my meeting with President XI
and I said to him
do you have a drug problem you would be
like what the hell is he talking about
of course wait didn't he tell the story
already a drug problem I mean I mean
today I know he's told it in other
rallies you what do you think you don't
have it any he talked about as I said he
talked about the fact that uh they have
quick trials they have quick trials and
and uh he said drug dealers if they want
to sell drugs it's okay but they're not
selling them in China and they're not
selling them in Singapore and they're
not selling them in certain other
countries where they have no drug
problem whatsoever
so we have to consider that I don't know
I haven't asked Brandon and Homan he did
tell the story so so twice he's told
this exact same story
wow bizarre
Let me refresh this thing something
weird's going on been committed to stop
drug distribution in the United States
and they just want to get a little
publicity for themselves they don't do
anything we need the death penalty if
you want to have a meaningful right so
we'll we'll do that I think you'll do
that
well Sheriff Joe I hear is here today
isn't Sheriff's up where is Sheriff Joe
look at Sheriff Joe
oh look at whoa racist Sheriff
horrible horrible person
you know Sheriff's show he knew borders
better than anybody in the history of
our country he looks at what's happened
to your state to Arizona with guys like
Kelly that don't have a clue they're
weak and incompetent and Joe is tough as
hell
sometimes too tough but we'll forgive
you for that job
I mean the pink underwear was a little
bit rough the pig text
that's okay we've heard it worse than
that
we've heard it worse than that but we
had no border problem Joe did we huh no
we had no border problem today those
same people are just pouring in at
levels nobody's ever seen But I want to
thank you Joe because you suffered
greatly I was very unfair what they did
to you you know I had the privilege of
giving Joe a pardon a complete and total
pardon that means
you know what the power is and if you
know what that means that means that
Sheriff Joe Arpaio is the cleanest one
here with all these politicians he's
cleaner than any of them he even cleaner
than Carrie I hate to say Carrie he's
that cleanest guy you can have so Joe
thank you very much great job great job
really we appreciate it you look
fantastic I got to know him I got to
know his incredible late wife who kept
him in check
she kept you in check Rachel but she was
great the first step to restoring Public
Safety is defeating the radical
Democrats this November and that starts
with throwing out
your extremist senator
but a weak man
Mark Kelly
Mark Kelly claims he's tried his best to
secure the Border but in fact for the
past two years Mark Kelly has been
deciding and he's been that deciding
50th vote to rubber stamp every Biden
Pelosi Schumer Bill and they Ram him
right through Congress he never fights
anything and he doesn't fight to get
safety for your border it's not like
he's fighting on the positive he could
do that I guess Kelly could have stopped
the Border nightmare with a snap of his
fingers but he didn't want to get
involved Kelly voted against money for
voter agents did you hear that Brandon I
don't think he's got your vote right he
voted against money for you people
that's not good
and yet he voted for 87 000 of those IRS
agents carrying guns he voted no on the
border wall he voted against my remain
in Mexico how good was that
I said to I said to the president of
Mexico no no no
you have to do two things we need 28 000
Mexican soldiers while I'm building the
wall no no no no we're not doing that
remember 55 000 of the 87 000 IRS agents
are are just to replace retiring IRS
agents and only about 2100 IRS agents in
the entire agency specifically in the
Criminal Division carry firearms its
lies all the way down it's great great
guy but he said no we're not giving you
twenty eight thousand soldiers I said
yes you are and you have to give us 28
000 soldiers we need them because people
are pouring through your country and
coming into our country
you can't do that and remain in Mexico
we want them to stay in your country so
that we can check them out and on
occasion somebody will be approved
otherwise they have to go back to the
country from which they came especially
with criminal records and we send
hundreds of thousands back and it was
going good really good but he said I
won't do it I said well if you're not
doing it I'm going to sign right on my
desk right now I have a signed tariff
agreement that charges Mexico 25 for
every car and every product it makes
coming into the United States which
would have amounted to billions and
billions of dollars a year Blake
and he said uh on the other hand I would
love to supply you with 28 000 soldiers
and I feel extremely good about uh
letting these criminals remain in Mexico
we would love to have all of these MS-13
gang members remain in Mexico you just
asked Tijuana ask the mayor of Tijuana
was he isn't MS-13 an American gang why
would they be in Mexico
deadly sanctions that's Kelly
deadly and Sanctuary cities are all over
the place he's always voting for secure
that's basically where you're supporting
I would say Brandon that's basically
where you're supporting and Sheltering
criminals for the most part there's
nothing good about Sanctuary cities
Kelly voted for every inflation causing
socialist spending Bill he voted to
raise your taxes by
326 billion dollars he voted against
there's a lot of space on the Rafters
behind Trump all of a sudden and some
folks seem to be sort of packing up
their signs
who looks the most bored here hmm either
he was told to do it he voted to drain
the Strategic National Petroleum Reserve
he co-sponsored a nationwide ban on
voter ID why doesn't he want voter ID
we'd like to see you know when you had
the Democrat National Convention in
Milwaukee in order to get in you had a
card bigger than a large man's chest
picture
fingerprints your social sick everything
it was the biggest identification it was
a voter ID you couldn't get in to the
Democrat National Convention unless you
wore this monster it was almost like a
vest it kept you warm it was so big and
are more people heading out I do now
they don't want voter ID Carrie for one
very simple reason because they want to
cheat it's the only reason there's no
other reason he voted to push critical
race theory on Pre-K and elementary
students and he voted for extreme
late-term abortion in the 40th week or
Beyond think of this
like the wacko governor of Virginia
recently the last Democrat Governor
where he said that you can have abortion
at any time even Beyond
the ninth month think of that she had to
have abortion during and Beyond the
ninth month that's a lie and he said
what you'll do is you'll sit down with
your doctor and decide and in some cases
the baby will be born and then you
essentially will execute the baby this
is what their plan it's untrue I
happened
to believe that we have the states do
that I tell you if you look at Ginsburg
if you look at many others but I also
believe strongly into three exceptions
like Ronald Reagan Ronald Reagan
believed in the exceptions
and I believe in the three exceptions
and I think it's very it's total chaos
on the stage behind Trump does anybody
have any idea what's happening
to Beyond essentially beyond the ninth
month and you can't
do that
rape incest the life of the mother those
three exceptions and you have the 15
weeks some people say the 16 weeks and
you bring it back into the states and
this is where it should have been
imagine believing that you could go to a
doctor with like a seven month old and
go doc could you kill the baby and the
dog goes sure sure somebody had to
explain it I said maybe I'll do it today
the radicals are them because they'll
kill the baby in the ninth month or
Beyond yeah and we can't let that happen
no country in the world lets that happen
there's not a country in the world so
Arizona they use that just as a fake
excuse because they're going to lose
big on crime they're going to lose
bigger in the economy they're losing on
almost everything they lose on the
military we have farmers who hates them
they want to defund your police so they
have nothing going
so they thought maybe when the Supreme
Court voted this way they could use that
as an issue but it turns out really when
you know about the real issue it's very
bad so I've done the best I can do it
but anybody really believe that it's
something that uh and many people do you
bring it back to the States I happen to
like the exceptions other people
disagree with that but it all worked out
and what really I think you're going to
vote for this time is crime and the
economy and inflation and all of the
horrible things that are happening to
our country because our country has
never been so low
in Arizona you need to vote this extreme
radical leftist Mark Kelly out of office
earlier this week Blake Masters
[Applause]
Blake Masters you know I got to see it a
little later I got to watch it last
night
who the hell was the third guy and some
guy kept interrupting that's all right
he's referring to the libertarian
candidate who actually was quite
entertaining we we streamed that debate
live like a nice man
but it was a little disconcerting but I
got to watch the debate and blank
Masters absolutely annihilated Mark
Kelly
Blake has had a tremendously successful
career in a very complicated business of
Technology he's a brilliant mind and a
very brave heart and a patriot and he's
exactly the kind of new blood we need in
the United States Senate we need new
blood we need strong blood we got to get
rid of some of these rhinos get him the
hell out
many times the rhinos are worse than the
Democrats because you don't know where
they're coming from but we figured it
out Blake will make it his mission to
restore The Sovereign borders of Arizona
and to protect the job safety and
well-being being of the people of your
state right like I think you're gonna
that's something so important to Blake
I've spent a lot of time with Blake and
he is really a patriot and he's a very
smart guy he's a tireless Champion for
free speech election integrity and for
putting America first so I would like to
have Lake masses come up just for a
minute and say hello he's already spoken
but say hello and I hope you get out and
vote for Blake he's going to be great
thank you dear God
remember you've got to praise Trump well
thank you Mr President
I mean my gosh really do you ever just
stop to think how much better were we
off just two or three years ago right we
had a secure border
crime was under control
you could actually afford to live prices
were pretty low gas was two dollars it
was good
let me tell you what that doesn't happen
by accident
that happened because of President Trump
and his America First policies wow
it is that simple and then what happened
Joe Biden happened
[Music]
Mark Kelly happened
[Applause]
just 22 months later everything's on
fire
our Southern border is a disaster
crime keeps going up the cost of
groceries actually the cost of every
single thing you need to live keeps
going up and up and up
but you know what we the people we the
people are waking up
we saw what successful leadership looks
like
looks a lot like President Trump
and now we see every day what failed
Democrat leadership looks like
and so the choice is clear
president Trump saved this country once
I can't wait to see him do it again what
do you think oh boy thank you
foreign
he was on message at least you go quick
and you praise Trump that's the only way
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Blake that was great you're
gonna win Blake you're gonna win you
know we talk about conservative it's
really Common Sense what we need is
common sense more than anything else
Blake you're gonna do great this
election day you also have the chance to
elect an America first All-Star a friend
of mine she's unbelievable as your
governor oh boy her name is Carrie Lake
she is scary
Arizona could not ask
[Applause]
[Music]
no you're so lucky I see some of the
people running in other places I say boy
is Arizona lucky you're so lucky but
Arizona could not ask for a governor
with more energy passion toughness
Brilliance Brilliance and determination
to secure your borders and stop violent
crime and keep the radical marxists away
from your kids and restore election
Integrity she's so strong on Election
knows what happened and bring jobs and
aperture the opportunity we want
opportunity back for your state your
state is taking a hit your gasoline
prices are second right now think of it
second to California
you're going way over five dollars and
you're gonna go up to seven eight nine
dollars and I've been predicted it's
happening probably not Carrie will get
up every single day she will fight the
media she will fight and stand up to the
abiding Administration and she will
truly deliver for Arizona when Kerry
wins this November the media's heads
will absolutely explode so that in
itself now she may win she's leading by
one and she is scary extreme scary
extreme arizonans must vote just with
absolutely no Talent with no personality
with no Charisma with no leadership
ability her name is Katie Hobb she's a
disaster she's an open borders fanatic
who denies there's even a small problem
at the border she was on the other day I
don't think we have a problem at the
Border in other words you have no choice
you have to get around
she tried to defund the Border Strike
Force
she hates people like Brandon she hates
people like you Brent and I can't that
means I don't like her right there she
doesn't like border patrol she doesn't
like ice she doesn't like law
enforcement she supported Biden's repeal
of my title 42 protections that's where
if you're not feeling too great you
don't come into our country we did that
during
the China virus I want to be accurate in
my description
she opposes the war
she voted to preserve Sanctuary cities
at a level that nobody nobody fought
harder than her for these Sanctuary
cities and they're killing you staying
killing our country Katie Hobbs is
proudly endorsed by three different to
fund the police groups you know that all
the police officers I got to take
pictures with them out these are great
people strong they had some of their
hands they got fingers like this like
that I said don't squeeze too tight
please okay
my hand still hasn't recovered hey you
know what I just noticed what's this
person doing are they complete are they
just on their phone
anybody know what's going on
do not seem to engage that's for sure
fund the cartels
Katie Hobbs voted against a law to
protect off-duty police officers that's
including ice and border patrol from
assault
and she voted to start sex education in
kindergarten that's pretty young
and just this morning she confirmed that
she supports completely unrestricted
abortion in other words nine months and
Beyond think of as a kid you put the
baby aside and then you execute the baby
let's take a look at Virginia take a
look at what happened with your past
Democrat Governor who is a total whack
job we call him member Michael Jackson
he said he imitated Michael Jackson when
he put the black face on right can you
imagine if I did that I don't think I'd
I don't think I would it wouldn't work
too well he got through and he put
blackface on and then he wanted to try
and do the moonwalk
and thank God for him his wife stopped
him he was going to do a moonwalk to
these totally crazy people look at all
of them back there I can't and they're
not leaving that means we haven't been
rough enough on them today they're not
leaving that's a lot of press wow I hope
they're here for Blake and for Carrie
and I hope you're going to say how great
they are no he wanted to imitate Michael
Jackson by doing a moonwalk across the
stage and I was with a man named
barishnikov once and he said you know
the truth as great a dancer as he was
one of the greatest probably the
greatest ever he said nobody could
moonwalk like Michael Jackson and this
Governor Wonder Micah that would have
been a disaster but his wife said no
don't do it she saved him
last but not least Katie Hobbs has been
a disaster for election Integrity she's
a crusader for rigged elections who
fought the Arizona audit she fought it
every step of the way and by the way the
real result of that audience we've
started to get a little off the the
prompter yeah around tens of thousands
of false votes but the Press never
wanted to look at what they call the
findings page did the
everybody get out and vote for this
unbelievable star I really believe she's
going to be a big star of the country
not just the party Terry Lake Carrie
please come up
here we go
horrified oh man Arizona you're too good
to me
do you love this guy or what
she knows what to do president Trump
loves Arizona but president Trump I
think Arizona loves you even more I
really do is that right
why wouldn't we love him think about
just go back in history here just a few
years record low inflation we were our
401ks looks great I just talked to a
neighbor who's lost a third of his
retirement savings since Joe Biden took
office we were doing great our kids were
safe because what's that guy invested in
sounds like some bad choices the great
times under President Trump and we miss
you so much president Trump
now I gotta tell you
I have some of these know-nothing
Consultants who tell me you know you
really need to back away from president
Trump right now
and I say to them
put down Hunter's crack pipe right now
oh boy
wouldn't it be horrible wouldn't it be
horrible what would it say about my
character if I stepped away from my
friends if I step away from my friends
that means I would step away from you
and I will never step away from the
people of Arizona
and so for those know-nothing
consultants and the media I want to show
you what it looks like when I step away
from president Trump
oh my God this is cringy
thank you Gary whoa sorry
[Applause]
to come oh God it's getting crazy also
with us tonight thank you Carrie we love
you
special person by the way get out you
got to vote these two and now you're
going to hear some other names that are
incredible but with us tonight is your
next Attorney General
ape comedy and he's great he's great he
knows what to do and he's going to get
it all done
and a man who's extremely
non-controversial
and you know the truth he loves your
state he loves the country
at all he's running for Secretary of
State he's leading everybody everybody
loves him because he's a warrior Mark
Fincher
marker
I hear you're doing incredible right
right
so bring it home mark very little time
left
but you're leading you're leading in
every poll and that's good but you're a
warrior an Abe you're a warrior so go
get them thank you
a woman that I've also fallen in love
with over a period of time she's an
incredible representative and she is she
will fight she was involved with
impeachment hooks number one impeachment
hoax number two and uh I think nobody
was tougher or smarter or better than
Debbie lesko
congresswoman our great congresswoman
thank you thank you very much Debbie
great job you do
another one I could say the same thing I
think here Debbie because this guy is
special and he's my friend and he's
tough and he loves the people in this
audience and he loves both sides he's a
he loves everybody he wants the people
of your state to be successful he wants
our country to be successful and he's
tough as hell Andy Biggs
thank you horrible people thank you Andy
I like that hat
and a friend of Andy and Debbie and a
friend of mine and somebody that fights
about as hard as anybody can fight
Congressman Paul gossar horrible radical
complete and total radical extremist
really really horrible
horrible and a woman who's extremely
low-key
very shy very quiet
I wish he had a little more room
but actually nobody has more oomph than
Marjorie Taylor green
and you can do that other thing normally
right the third element
thank you Madre great
and two people that are running for
congress and I think will win based on
everything I'm seeing Eli Crane and
Kelly Cooper and
and Eli I've already endorsed
Eli I've already endorsed and you're not
getting them dead and welcome to
everybody joining us from the stream of
Grand Master Benjamin Feingold welcome
everybody we are watching an old man
essentially yell at proverbial clouds
that's more or less what we're watching
here I welcome you great job but we
appreciate it so those two are gonna
We'll add to the all week we will have
debates for 2022 candidates so make sure
you're following because the the debates
may actually be substantive this is not
substantive at all it's a couple of
Democrats anyway keep up the good work
everybody thanks thanks Debbie
a woman who's as strong as they come and
as smart as they come and fought for
election Integrity which people
are starting to come and but she fought
and she has really proven the point and
it continues Wendy Rogers Wendy yeah
welcome great job everybody great job
and a friend of mine and then somebody
that is very unsung because this man is
this Billy he's another Warrior and he's
out there all the time and he just works
he doesn't want to do anything but work
he just wants to get the job done Sonny
Borelli Sonny thank you sonny
yeah thank you sonny
State Senate candidates Anthony Kern
Robert scantleberry David Farnsworth oh
David oh what a good deal David
[Applause]
you beat uh a certain man that
was a super Rhino didn't you you were
the man that beat him I endorsed David
you beat him what by what uh it's hard
to tell who defeated whom when Trump
tells these stories a big win I was very
proud that was good that's one you can
put in your mantle and in retrospect for
him look at him he's Central Casting it
wasn't even hard he's probably saying
that wasn't so hard but the people are
they don't want the Rhinos by the way
for everybody joining me Mike pillow AKA
Mike Lindell the CEO of my pillow will
be joining me on Tuesday on the show
Ellie case Shelly hi Shelly great job
thank you for all the help
we won it twice that we did better the
second time shall we Ambassador Rick
Grinnell a fighter
Rick Grinnell
he's a great great man a great fighter
and he's got a lot of future another one
with a lot of future future and a man
who uh just he's got a fuchsia future
that's nice alliteration cash Patel
where's cash
thank you cash
and I introduced Joe Arpaio but I'll
introduce him again because there's
nobody I'm telling you oh boy if we had
him if we had him at the border we
wouldn't even be up here talking
I'd also like to while we can please uh
Sheriff Mark Lamb
so
this is how many people has he
recognized so far 20 I mean it's just
endless and meaningless
Central Casting
and another man he's the single greatest
purchaser events in the history of our
country Mike Lindell
there must be a lot of money in pillows
because I've never seen anybody that
could buy ads like that we're doing a
classroom
yep and he'll be on the show joining me
Tuesday I plan to ask Mike pillow you
know Mike you predicted Trump would be
reinstated on December 4th January 8th
January 19th March 14th April 18th
August definitely by the Fall before
Thanksgiving by Christmas by the end of
the year by the following April
what happened on March 26th that
prevented the reinstatement joined by
two very special guests the parents of
an incredibly kind and brave young woman
a beautiful
unbelievable person who came from
Arizona
and you know who we're talking about
Kayla Mueller Kayla was a person who
after volunteering to provide
humanitarian Aid in Syria she wanted to
help people it didn't have to be in
Arizona it didn't have to be in our
country Kayla wanted to help people but
she was kidnapped by ISIS and held
captive directly by the Isis leader
al-baghdadi who as you remember we gave
him a bad sent off into hell
he was badly psyched off
Kayla was a beautiful young woman and Al
baghdadi spotted her
and they grabbed her
and she lived like hell
but what she's done is so incredible in
so many other ways and
2019 when you look at what took place
with that attack and the attack that we
did and we named the attack and we named
the number in honor of Kayla and I'd
like to just say that Carl and Marsha
her parents are with us
tonight we started off today and now
we're tonight right and I just would
like to have them stand up and if they'd
like they could come up because as far
as I'm concerned you are real here as
you produce somebody who is an
incredible incredible come on up come on
up for a second
come on up
dear daughter
will never be forgotten Kaylor will
never be
forgotten and we will Vanquish radical
Islamic terrorism from the face of the
Earth
please
[Applause]
I'm not running for office first of all
but
a president that cares about you and you
and the average American we can tell you
firsthand this man and the people that
he puts together
they care
they have treated us like no other
government agency and uh we'd love to
see him back in office so let's let's
all vote Republican
great people unbelievable daughter
unbelievable person
when Republicans take back Congress this
November we will fight for the people of
Arizona we will win for the people of
Arizona we promise one of the first
things we must do is stand up for
parents rights can you believe I'm even
saying that we're going to fight for
parents he's going to do the anti-trans
rant now everybody get ready fight for
parents rights 10 years ago if you said
that to say you crazy my guess is he'll
say the following no teacher should ever
ever be allowed to teach transgender
transgender military which we had it out
and out of every part of our federal
state and local governments and at long
last every parent in America must be
empowered to opt out of the forced
indoctrination in the classroom and send
their child to the public private
Charter religious or home school of
their choice
we will also this is very Politically
Incorrect but I will say it anyway we
will keep men the hell out of women's
Force
no teachers should ever be allowed to
teach transgender to our children
without parental consent
if you can believe that one some
teachers are teaching cherry
just about the fruit they're teaching
Cherry another one of our highest
priorities under a republican Congress
will be to stop left-wing censorship and
restore Free Speech these people free
speech in America so go out and sign up
now for a truth social it's the hottest
thing you gotta it's doing a great job
and frankly I think the engagement is
much much better than Twitter which is
being obliterated as essential and
everywhere the Republican party has
truth social is about to go completely
bankrupt forms including Universal voter
ID
citizenship confirmation if that's okay
in other words I would like to know that
you're a citizen they don't want to do
that can you imagine they don't want to
know that you're a citizen of the United
States before you vote no more fake drop
boxes no private money pouring into
local election offices
417 million came in from one person
what a crooked deal that was and
ultimately we need same-day voting with
only paper ballots that's what we need
remember Trump voted weeks early France
by mail 36 million people voted Carrie
they had no problem they had a winner
they had a loser everybody went home at
11 o'clock and that was the end of that
they didn't fight about it for years and
all the things that we found out you
wouldn't believe I mean you know most of
you know they stuffed the paper the
ballot boxes you know there's so many
things that there were so many ways of
cheating
but we're just 30 days away from the
most important midterm election in
American history and we need a landslide
so big that the radical lift they can't
they just can't the radical left can
that's a double glitch right there sure
that the radical left does not trying to
steal your election
in many ways it's the thing I'm most
worried about because I think you have
candidates that can't lose
but there's an expression that is often
used and we saw it in 2020 that the vote
counter is oftentimes far more important
than the candidate we cannot let that
happen we cannot let that happen and a
very good thing with this is a crowd
that understands history just that I
believe Carrie feels his and Abe and
everyone else
but if you can vote on Election Day in
person hey this is funny plaid pancakes
just uh gifted a twitch subscription to
the actual Congressman Matt Gates on
Twitch who now is actually on Twitch
very much to your benefit in fact that
happened to the primer Carrie was losing
it we're worried I'd say what's going on
and then all of a sudden explosion
happened and you went easily right
because they voted on Election Day but I
hope they're going to do that again vote
on Election Day as opposed to sending in
a potentially fake ballot potential
whatever you do get out and vote this is
the year we're going to take back the
house we're going to take back the
Senate we're going to take back America
and in 2024 most importantly we are
going to take back our magnificent our
beautiful our incredible white house
we're going to take it back
is he winding down together we will
fight for more jobs for American
families fair trade for American workers
and more American factories forging more
products stamped with that beautiful
phrase made in the USA
President Biden yesterday
you saw that right he said I just want
people
to remember two words right
I just want people to remember two words
made in America everybody he said this
that's what he said
I said was he kidding and then he said
no he was
uh well that took place yesterday
we will shut down Biden's border
disaster reinstitute our strong remain
in Mexico policy not easy to get that
how do you tell Mexico we want everybody
to say in your country not ours
but I got it and I got it strong
strengthened the Patriots of ice and
border patrol Brandon and we will again
in Catch and Release we will end chain
migration we will end the Visa Lottery
which is a disgrace and we will clamp
down on illegal immigration just like we
did less than two years ago and we had
the safest Border in the history of our
country we will stop the crime wave and
democrat-run cities all right what do
people think in chat is he skipping the
Q Anon music piece today or is he going
to do it away from our police they want
to take protection away so that the
police officer can individually be sued
can you believe this
we will restore Law and Order in America
a Democrats not even allowed to use that
phrase they'll be written out of the
party we will hold China accountable for
unleashing the virus upon the world they
will be in some form accountable we will
defend our constitution we will defend
the Second Amendment which is under
siege and we will proudly uphold the
judeo-christian values and principles of
our Nations founding
we will restore patriotic education to
our schools and we will teach our
children to love their country honor our
history and to always respect our Great
American flag
in conclusion are
Mega movement make America great again
is by far the greatest political
movement in the history of our country
together we are standing up against some
of the most menacing forces entrenched
interests and vicious opponents our
people have ever seen despite great
outside dangers our biggest threat
Remains the sick Sinister demented and
evil people from within a country you
saw some of them up on the screen didn't
you but no matter how big or powerful
the corrupt radical left Democrats that
we are fighting against may be
you must never forget this nation does
not belong to them this nation belongs
to you and you
and you
this nation belongs to you
wow
this nation belongs to you
this is your home this is your heritage
in our American Liberty is your god
given right from Phoenix to Sedona from
Flagstaff to Florence and from Yuma to
right here in Massachusetts
[Music]
[Applause]
I love it it's actually closer to the
real pronunciation in Spanish right
Missa that's shocking
and they work hard too they work hard we
stand on the shoulders of red-blooded
American Patriots who poured out their
hearts sweat and soul for our country
and for our freedom this great state was
settled by some of the toughest men and
strongest women ever to walk the face of
the Earth he says that arizonans were
Wyatt Earp and Doc Holliday became
American legends wow wow that's pretty
cool it's where the Great American West
became the American dream
it started here and Arizona is the state
where generations of pioneers and
Prospectors Miners and ranchers Cowboys
and cattle hands Marshals and lawmen we
have a lot of them with us tonight thank
you
tame the frontier Brave the blazing sun
and showed the entire world How the West
Was Won right they gave everything they
had to make America into the greatest
nation in the history of the world oh
he's doing it
he's doing it
it's getting culty
[Music]
but now we are a nation in Decline we
are a failing Nation we are a nation
that has the highest inflation in 50
years and where the stock market
finished the worst first half of the
year since 1872.
[Music]
likewise we are a nation that has the
highest energy cost in its history we
are no longer energy independent or
energy dominant as we were just two
short years ago
we are a nation that is begging
Venezuela Saudi Arabia and many other
nations for oil this is scary please
please please help us Joe Biden says yet
we have more liquid gold right under our
feet than any other country
we are a nation that is consumed by the
radical left screen New Deal
yet everyone knows that the green New
Deal will lead to our destruction
we are a nation whose leaders are
demanding all electric cars
even though they can't go far costs too
much whose batteries are produced in
China with materials only available in
China
when an unlimited amount of gasoline is
available inexpensively
there is not unlimited gasoline guys
eighty percent of Norwegian new car
sales are electric they're a nation that
ended
just as the price of oil reached an
all-time high what other country would
do such a thing
we are a nation that surrendered in
Afghanistan leaving behind dead soldiers
American citizens and 85 billion dollars
worth of the finest military equipment
anywhere in the world
and we are a nation that allowed Russia
to devastate a country Ukraine killing
hundreds of thousands of people and it
will only get worse it would have never
happened with me as you're really moving
stuff ever and it didn't for four
straight years
and China with Taiwan
is next we are is this woman genuinely
about to cry
what on Earth is going on party like
never before
we've got a Federal Bureau of
Investigation that won't allow bad
election-changing facts to be presented
to the public
where Hunter Biden's laptop from hell
was Russian disinformation when the FBI
hard to imagine there would be a dry eye
in the house with something this moving
oh boy briefly refused to investigate
the
big parodies and fraud egregious and we
have a president who is cognitively
impaired and in no condition to lead our
country and is now casually talking
about nuclear war with Russia
which would be World War III and far
more devastating than any of the
previous Wars because of the Weaponry
that no one even wants to think about or
discuss
we are a nation that no longer has a
free press
fake news is all you get
and they are truly the enemy of the
people
we are a nation where free speech is no
longer allowed where crime is this
person right here praying or sleeping I
can't tell and or just on their phone
covered in 2021
then in 2020 we are a nation that is
allowing Iran to build a massive nuclear
weapon and China to use the trillions of
dollars that has taken from us to build
a military to rival our own
and just two years ago we had Iran China
Russia and North Korea in check they
weren't going to do a thing against us
and everyone knows it and perhaps most
importantly we are a nation that is no
longer respected or listened to
around the world we are a nation that in
many ways has become a joke
and we are a nation
that is hostile to Liberty freedom and
faith we are a nation whose economy is
collapsing into a cesspool of Ruin whose
supply chain is broken who stores are
not stocked whose deliveries are not
coming and whose educational system is
ranked at the book you do the airplanes
thing where flights are canceled
sometimes or late a nation where large
packs of sadistic criminals and thieves
are allowed to go into stores and openly
Rob them beat up and kill their workers
and customers and leave with arm loads
of goods but with no retribution with
the authority of our great police has
been taken where their families and
pensions have been threatened and their
lives would be destroyed for the mere
mention of the words law enforcement
we are a nation where Fentanyl and all
other forms of illegal drugs are easier
to get then formula for our beautiful
little babies a nation who's once
revered airports are dead here it is
they're a crowded mess you sit and wait
for hours and then are notified that the
plane won't leave and they have no idea
when it will where ticket prices have
tripled they don't have the pilots to
fly the planes they don't seek qualified
air traffic controllers anymore and the
chicken at Chipotle at the airport is
brought in pre-seasoned not genuinely
cooked to order it's confidence its
willpower and its strength
we are a nation that has lost its way
but we are not going to allow this
horror to continue two years ago we were
a great nation and we will soon be a
great nation again right very soon
[Music]
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome the
45th president you who built this
country and it is hard working what was
that I didn't play that who are going to
save our country what that we will stand
up to the radical F Democrats and the
dangerous unpatriotic rhinos and we will
fight for America like no one has ever
fought before
there is no mountain we cannot climb
there is no Summit we cannot reach there
is no challenge we cannot meet there is
no Victory we cannot have I did not do
that we will not Bend we will not break
we will not yield we will never give in
we will never give up and we will never
ever back down
[Music]
as long as we are confident United and
loyal to the cause the tyrants we are
fighting do not stand a chance of
Victory because we are Americans and
Americans kneel to God and God Alone the
silent majority is back and stronger
than ever before right
my fellow citizens this incredible
journey we run together has only just
begun and it is time
to start talking about greatness for our
country again
We Are One movement one people one
family and one glorious nation under God
so with the help of everyone here today
and the citizens all across how did
everyone know to stand then America
powerful again
we will make America wealthy again
we will make America strong again
we will make America proud again
we will make America safe again oh
stupid and we will make America great
again thank you very much thank you very
much God bless you all
[Music]
and they did cut the mic too soon too
that was everything about it's weird
[Music]
what a mess huh
truly embarrassing really really really
embarrassing
but there's people who love this crap
they really do
well listen
I appreciate everybody joining me
um tomorrow night we will hopefully have
a little more substance
um it'll be the JD Vance versus Tim Ryan
debate one of the most important Senate
races going on it'll be completely
Bonkers I predict and that'll be at 6 30
PM East tomorrow
I hope you will all join me I really
really really do
um
oh hold on there's another one of these
coveted conspiracy theorists this is
their first chat ever and they are
banned man a lot of really really crazy
stuff in the chat we've had to ban so
many people today it's really insane all
right everybody
um I'll see everybody tomorrow okay
stream tomorrow we have the oh debates
almost every day of the week
look forward to seeing you let's uh
let's do the whole thing thank you
[Music]
[Music]
emerge for only in sinks and showers
elephants and bathrooms
ten times
[Music]
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet